Sure.
Okay.
Grounds.
You
shouldn't stay
Barrick.
So what did you say?
They're saying some of the nose that every,
what they're thumbing their nose at every victim in Hebrew victim in here coming
in
as we're saying before we were rudely cut off,
rudely cut off.
We uh,
we started earlier but we didn't have any sound.
Something was going on with the youth stream feed.
So we decided to Redo everything and uh,
you know,
saying this is,
this is a very strange song.
Well,
I mean it's strange that anybody would actually record it.
There's,
I think that there's something sad about it.
I mean there's something like kind of pathetic about the passion and the guy's
voice.
You know what I mean?
Like he sounds like a,
it's like a baby was like an infant.
Like he's believes everything.
That guy believes everything.
And he's like,
you know,
I'm going to do my part.
I'm going to make a song.
Brian,
what the fuck are you doing?
I just fucked a cup of flashlights.
Brian set up.
That was mad complicated.
Yeah.
We fucked up folks that we had a,
we had a serious issue.
We couldn't get any sound.
Hmm.
It was ugly.
And uh,
Brian pulled it together.
Somehow or another we had to swap laptops.
I think my laptop sound port might've shit the bed fucking Max.
Amazing.
It's because you fucking merch queer.
Um,
shut that song off before it rots my brain.
Right now
I'm here with Duncan Trussell Patriot,
ladies and gentlemen.
A true,
true patriot.
A man of the people.
That's right.
And a big supporter of the fleshlight.
Is that correct?
Duncan and the tea party.
You support the tea party as well?
Yeah.
And the flashlight.
I sat down real quick.
So this is our sponsor is our s commercial part of the show here.
The fleshlight,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you've never used one,
I don't recommend you jump right into the butthole version.
Start off with a dick one.
What?
No,
don't do that.
But you can keep this on your refrigerator and nobody would think you're
appropriate.
It's like a little beer camp.
Who keeps it beer in the refrigerator.
You don't,
what are you doing?
You want to be here?
Oh,
I thought you said freezer.
I really heard you say freezer.
Why do weird,
I swear to God,
I heard Freezer Duncan Trussell standup comedian.
Good Pal,
former roommate.
He's on the show today.
Duncan,
thank you very much for coming on board.
Thanks for having me on.
I'm sorry we were so fucked up.
Put your headphones on.
So share what you sound like.
You'd rather not.
I want you to though.
Hate my voice.
Either way,
my voice sounds,
let's try it.
You can't hear it when you're a hello.
Hello.
Here we are.
So for people who don't know you,
Duncan,
Trussell,
t r u two SS e two L's
dot com find out all kinds of shit about you.
Sort of find out about your bio.
Do you ever get chicks that I've seen you online seeing some of the stuff that
you've done and say,
I don't like send you an email?
Like,
wow,
I think,
uh,
I think you're really creative.
Yeah.
It's the best.
It happens once every equinox at the most,
but on occasion I,
yeah,
anytime you get really creative.
Yeah.
I really think you're cool.
I liked your website by the way.
It's very trippy and crazy.
It's really fun to get stoned and explore your website together.
Yeah,
I built the whole thing.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's cool.
I love the choice of music.
Oh,
Calypso John Denver.
And do you have to do,
have to have rights to use that music or just until anybody tells ya?
I'm just waiting for the cease and it says from,
fuck man,
I'm not going to happen.
It should be free.
It's dead.
You should should be free like Michael Jackson.
We should all be able to sell and make money off of him.
Can I give a lot to make money off the phone?
But you should be able to just listen to his music.
You shouldn't have to pay.
He's dead.
Can I,
can I give some John Denver Trivia?
Sure.
Supposedly.
And you know,
I don't know where I heard this from,
but it seems like it came from a good source.
He,
his corpse when they found his corpse was being eaten by starfish.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So has starfish.
So he crashed in the ocean,
crashing the ocean,
and he was being,
I guess anyone who crashes in the ocean,
it's going to happen,
but somehow there's something either really beautiful about that are really,
really fucked up.
But starfish were devouring his corpse.
It wasn't he in some sort of a,
um,
it was some sort of a test plane or a,
it w w it wasn't what it was like,
what was it?
What kind of plane was it?
I knew it was one of those planes that kills rock stars.
It's like,
what the fuck is it with rock stars that they get in the shittiest planes and
fly over bodies of water?
It's like,
you know,
that's how you're,
you're going to die if you're in a little plane with a band.
Oh,
it was like a one in four chance you're dead if you're filming videos like in
The Bahamas and shit like that.
That's just how you got a role.
You got to get one of those propeller planes.
I know that in one of those a couple of years ago when went to alumni,
when all your land in Honolulu and then you'd take a little puddle jumper,
it's fucking spooky,
man.
It's the worst.
That's some old technology son.
But it's like God waits for their bands to getting those little planes and then
strikes him.
You should know that that's the living Stevie Ray Vaughan.
How many guys went down from planes and helicopters and shit?
Yeah,
if you're on a puddle jumper with Depeche mode,
you're dead.
Forget it.
Cause you're gone.
Been very horny to think about how many fucking
people,
how many people big bopper and um,
buddy Holly,
right?
Yep.
They died.
Um,
Leonard's Kennard right.
Gone.
Stevie Ray Vaughan helicopter.
Yeah.
Rocky Marciano plane crash.
I know he's not,
but I'm throwing them there.
Anyway.
Kurt Cobain,
it's the same idea.
Get off those foot.
But for real,
if you're,
if you're a,
yeah.
What about j what?
Kurt Cobain and Courtney love?
Lisa left getting a plane.
No,
Courtney love killed him.
What the fuck you talking about this any more?
We're talking about.
We're talking about people dying and planes.
Dude,
I know Lisa Lazy.
I sent,
what was her name?
Brian.
I forgive Brian.
I,
I used to think there were something wrong with Brian,
but then Brian told me his story about how he was living in this apartment and
they were pumping carbon dioxide from the furnace into his bedroom for like two
years and it made him half retarded.
Totally.
For Real.
It's really,
it's totally true.
It's totally true.
Wait,
you really think you have like something happened?
It was Brandon there.
Yeah.
They cooked his brain with carbon monoxide.
I think it made him a superhero dioxide or monoxide?
No,
he's a superhero.
It's like the one,
the spider bit a Spiderman.
Is it carbon monoxide?
Why do you think I can make retarded videos outside of this?
It's been poisoned.
You guys it monoxide or dioxide dioxide is what you breathe out,
right?
I oxide.
You breathe out.
Monoxide is what makes you make great viral videos.
Right?
See,
right.
You could trace cats up.
Do you ever look back to the days before you lived in that place and how,
what?
What would have been like no,
because that was my guy.
I was tripping and stuff,
you know,
before that.
So.
So you just cooked your brain right from the get go?
Totally.
But I take,
you know,
a lot of that raise a virtual now,
so I should be fine.
Right.
Do you think that was very trials?
Really?
The Shit?
Oh,
I totally love it.
Yeah.
I believe in it so much.
Did you think maybe it's partly placebo effect?
Probably.
Yeah.
Talk to me taking any vitamins these days.
Can't you tell?
Yes,
I can.
No,
I have,
you know,
I,
I took a,
I was telling you I took um,
this are Reishi and fused.
Yeah.
Tell me about that.
These are marijuana drops,
right?
Yeah.
There's never a fucking lack of creativity in these crazy weed shops.
They're always coming up with new things.
So tell what exactly is this?
This is a,
um,
this is,
uh,
ratios and I'm probably mispronouncing it,
but it's a,
how you spell it.
It's apparently the super healthy fungus that when I read on Wikipedia what it
does,
it like somehow helps you if you're having chest problems or chest pains,
I guess it like supposedly helps you.
This is Chinese herbs who the fuck knows if it's real but tastes like shit.
Tastes like [inaudible] but the,
the infused part of it is awesome.
So the infuser with THC.
Yes.
So you get,
is it,
what is the difference between that effect and the regular like THC drops effect
that when you take it you're like,
oh,
this fucking awful.
But yeah,
you feel like you've earned it.
[inaudible] you're like suffering through it.
Like you've got a mini Iowasca trip.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like,
but you know,
I don't know.
I mean,
it's all placebo by the way.
The placebo effect is underrated because placebo effect is powerful man.
And so when you're,
you know,
normal.
So when you eat pot,
anyone who's eating pot knows it's very strong and there's like a chance
somewhere in that trip that you can go a little dark or get a little paranoid or
things can seem weird.
But if you've been taking an herbal Chinese super medicine with the drop,
then when shit starts getting weird and you think,
no,
I'm on [inaudible],
I'm on a Chinese herb that's healthy,
and then it kind of vanishes.
The demons a little bit.
Really?
No,
it's not.
She worked with me.
Didn't help at all.
I just,
I was making,
I was kind of making out because I took it and went snorkeling on a reef.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It was fucking awesome.
Deep.
Did you go how deep,
like say if,
uh,
we at the bottom of the pool,
like how high were you?
How high,
how high was fucking high?
I was,
I was out on the pool,
the bottom of the pool charter boat.
I'm sitting there because we were like,
you know what?
We're going snorkeling.
Let's go hunter s Thompson style just,
and I was drinking.
I wasn't driving.
I was like,
I remember like it was streaming down my face into my beard.
I'm drinking it and still like not,
you know that thing where you,
when you're eating pot and you're kind of jolly and you're underestimating it's
power,
you're like,
yeah,
fuck it,
let's go nuts.
And then like 45 minutes in sudden you're like,
oh,
why did I do that?
I was on a chartered boat and I started,
I always in everyone's happy and there's kids wander grants in Hawaii,
everything's beautiful and I'm like,
oh well you're going to be the first person who goes insane on this boat.
We,
the first time when you went just started raving and ranting on a boat and
there's kids around,
I'm thinking,
you're going to ruin these kids vacations.
I looked,
they were like,
you know,
Hawaii is beautiful and he's fucking red cliffs and I swear to God,
I looked up and I thought,
I saw like,
you know Raiden from mortal Kombat like I thought I saw it like this,
like person wearing one of those poned hats and like kind of blown.
I'm like,
all you're seeing Hawaiian gods,
that's like some Hawaiian Guardian spirit that's aware of you and doesn't want
you to be there cause you're a Honky,
we're taking mushrooms and seen like Aztec imagery seemed like Mexican,
uh,
imagery.
Uh,
I've taken LSD and have seen,
uh,
no,
I when I was real like,
um,
uh,
was Sanskrits but never asked.
I've see I've taken mushrooms and seen like at like Mayan language and like,
you know,
that style of,
ancient Mexican culture,
the Mayans and you know,
all the,
they're crazy language that was like little drawings,
images.
I've like seen that shit in the sky.
Sure.
And when I'm on mushrooms I've seen like,
you know,
all this crazy Mayan imagery.
Now I don't know if that's because I had seen it before and my imagination was
running wild and I was like,
you know,
just creating images that I've already witnessed and creating them in the sky.
That's very possible.
It's very possible.
That's what was going on.
It's also very possible that they made those images because they got fucked on
mushrooms and they saw
that shit in the sky.
And then they drew it.
That seems to be even more likely.
And I throw out another possibility.
Sure.
Um,
if you,
I,
and whoever out there is smart and listening to this please correct me,
but I think it's a Chomsky is a linguist.
Noam Chomsky is a linguist and there's basically,
um,
theories of where language comes from,
his language,
something you learn or is language something encoded into your brain.
Um,
cause some people think that language is something that's already kind of built
into your brain.
And it's,
it's like waiting the flower according to what culture you get born into and who
you're around.
Because it's such an incredibly complex thing to learn.
People wonder if like,
you know,
is the brain of blank slate when you're born or they're already these things
sort of in there waiting to come out.
So the idea is that when you are hallucinating these symbols,
it wasn't as though you are projecting something you'd already seen.
And it wasn't as though the Aztecs were hallucinating or like,
oh,
we should use these symbols to,
uh,
as our,
as our language.
It's more like that's already deep inside your brain and when you're tripping it
kind of comes out and you're seeing like an Uber language,
you know,
or some kind of like original primal language,
like fucking Hebrew.
Look at Hebrew.
That's so psychic that it's such a cycle.
It is,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Maybe you,
maybe you're right.
I mean I don't know.
But one of the things that I've seen many,
many times in in psychedelic states,
like especially even just eating pot when I closed my eyes is cartoon,
like imagery,
like cartoon,
like strange morphing type of imagery.
And what,
what strikes me about a lot of the Mayan shit is that all these,
you know,
is it pictographs?
Is that how you would,
I don't know exactly what you'd call it,
but all these different images,
they look very cartoon like,
yeah.
You know,
the dragon's look very silly and cartoon.
Like everything is almost like psychedelic.
It's like these people were living in real danger,
but yet they had the peace of mind,
the creativity to draw the dangerous things and almost like,
uh,
they like lessened your,
your,
your worry about them.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weird thing that cultures do with,
with,
with predators.
I mean,
we still do it today with like a polar bears.
Polar bears are some of the most dangerous pairs you could ever come across.
But we have them selling Coca Cola and Klondike bars and being all silly and
sliding on the snow and they're fucking vicious murderers that live in the
coldest part of the world,
you know?
So we do,
we do it because we have a separation from them.
They're not a part of our daily lives.
They're not infiltrating the cities.
If they were,
you know,
we,
we would,
we would want to kill them all.
And we wouldn't ever think of him as being a happy thing.
But these fucking people were living in the jungle,
man.
They were living in the jungle around Jaguars and snakes and all these,
they were doing so much drugs.
There were drawing everything in cartoons,
right.
These people tripping their fucking balls off.
You know,
like when people say like that,
the Mayans like had this answer and the Mayans had this calendar that can
predict
lunar eclipses.
And I go,
you know what,
so do we,
we can predict all that shit too.
And we don't know the fucking future.
You're telling these people would never invented shoes.
These,
these people figured out the future.
They figured out how that the age is going to end.
Really.
You know,
come on man.
More likely they were stone age people who did a fuck load of drugs and came up
with some really,
really cool shit.
What about the cargo cult theory?
You know,
that,
what is that?
You know what a cargo cult is?
No.
So again,
brilliant person out there,
correct me.
Cause like I kind of remember things and then I fuck him up in my translation of
them.
Right.
But,
uh,
during one of the wars,
maybe it was World War II,
um,
uh,
in the South Pacific,
I guess they would like parachute supplies down,
right?
And so the supplies would come down and they land on these islands that had
primitive people who'd never seen this shit before.
And so what,
what,
what happened is a colt would emerge based on trying to figure out how to get
those supplies to fall out of the sky again.
So this really great shit that you'd never seen basically from an alien.
If you're a South Pacific islander and you've been slurp and coconuts eating
fish,
eating bananas,
that's the extent of what you understand.
And all of a sudden this giant fucking thing on a parachute comes zooming out of
the sky filled with flashlights,
maybe a radio fabric you've never,
it's Roswell.
It's like an alien impact and it changes your culture because it's like shit
you've never seen.
You have no way to explain it fell out of the sky.
So that's a co a cargo cult.
It's something that emerges around that event where you try to reenact whatever
you were doing at that time when the thing fell out of the sky.
So if you are like cutting fish or do it,
so whatever,
you know,
having a certain celebration or if it happened
during hunting fish,
whatever.
So that's what they do.
That's what they do.
They cut do all day is a big part of the very small,
I mean the,
the window of what they do is,
you know,
yeah.
Hunting and gathering.
So you look at those fucking pyramids,
right.
And you look at them like maybe they were visited by Egyptians now I think now
I,
this is not something,
you know,
they do believe that Africans came to earth or came to a North America a long,
long time ago.
The old MACs,
the Omex,
they don't understand much about the old mex at all.
They know it's a civilization that goes back,
I think it's like thousands of years.
And they were the oldest civilization or they know advanced civilization North
America.
And they know nothing about their language.
They know nothing.
Right.
But they have African features.
They have these old Mac,
these carved heads.
There's giant carved heads from,
they don't know where they dragged the fucking stone from.
The stones are gigantic and they're perfectly carved.
Like really like detailed African faces,
big fix,
lit,
thick lips,
African features.
Well,
no,
I don't think it's there.
Visited.
I mean
that is,
I mean,
look,
the old macs,
it came from Africa most likely and came to North America or South America.
I mean they were there,
they were there,
they were in Mexico.
Me Throw my theory out and it's just a theory.
I don't really believe it,
but I like thinking about it.
What if you FO's looked like those pyramids and fucking Ufo is landed for a
little while and gave them all their advanced technology and gave them all the
crazy shit and then flew off and just go deep into the what if droid.
Yeah,
this is deep in the what if drawer.
This is way underneath a lot of other what ifs.
But like,
so if you think about it,
those fucking pyramids kind of look like they could be spaceships.
Like whenever,
I think it's spacious,
I think,
why wouldn't it look like a pyramid?
It could be a pyramid,
so maybe it's maybe fucking,
they were visited by advanced intelligence that looked like those pyramids,
but still
it's still,
the problem with the pyramids is not that,
the problem with the Pyramids is the incredible mathematical equations that are
required to create something so perfect.
There's 2 million,
300,000 stones in the period of the great Giza pyramid.
The Great Pyramid of Giza.
Yeah.
That to me to think about how many fucking stones at is,
it's the last time they weigh between two and 80 tons and some of them,
the ones from the king's chamber,
we're cut from a Corey that was like 500 miles away.
I mean it's amazing man.
And they were there.
They're perfectly put in place.
You ever seen the king's chamber?
You know,
were they in the,
in the Great Pyramid?
It's insane.
They don't have any idea how they built it.
They have no idea how they got these incredibly large stones cut so perfectly
and so smooth and they've found literally they found bore marks in the
sarcophagus is from a diamond bit drill.
Right.
So it's like shit that we have today.
Another,
what's that called?
I'm sorry to cut you off that it just because it's another fascinating aspect of
this stuff you're talking about,
which is,
shit,
there's a name for this kind of archeology where people of crimes,
those script batteries,
you know what I mean?
Or you'll find,
yeah.
Thinking of cryptozoology but yeah,
no,
yeah,
yeah.
I know what you're talking.
You'll find like,
uh,
it's something that there's no way that it should exist back then.
It almost indicates time travelers.
Sure.
You ever will not,
I'm not Tom Travel,
but have you ever looked into Graham Hancock?
Have you ever read any of this stuff?
No.
I know that I want to give you fingerprints of the gods before you leave.
It's one of my favorite books and this guy,
Graham Hancock,
is an archeologist and he traveled all over the world looking in all these
ancient civilizations and ancient structures and studied all the,
the different,
you know,
uh,
the,
um,
different,
a cataclysmic event,
um,
stories that every single religion seems to have that are in the eye of
Gilgamesh.
And in the Bible and what he believes is that somewhere around 10,000 years ago,
there was some event on earth and there was a super advanced civilization that
existed before that.
And we have been around a lot longer than we think.
And that what,
what the pyramids are literally is people rediscovering some shit that a super,
super advanced civilization that had been reset many thousands of years ago.
The w w what we see,
like when you see like the Great Pyramid and the Sphinx and all these things
that they can't explain the finks and closure.
What we see is the proof that there was some sort of a super advanced
civilization,
many,
many thousands of years before worthy archeologists currently date to be,
you know,
the time they built the pyramids.
And there's a guy named John Anthony West that has dedicated his entire life to
trying to let people a look at Egypt and a different way.
And she,
and he believes that the Egyptian,
uh,
the,
the drawings,
the depictions of ferals,
they go back over 34,000 years.
But for whatever reason,
conventional Egyptologists are unwilling to look at that kind of evidence.
They don't want to look at anything that makes it seem like everything is all
fucked up.
And there was some sort of an event that hasn't been documented in the people
that we think of as Egyptians maybe never even built us in the first place.
They might've been like the people that moved into all this shit.
And you know this conversation we're having about the pyramid,
the Egyptians were having it too,
I'm sure.
What the fuck is that right where this should come from.
Exactly.
People have been saying that for exactly and we found it like second hand,
they found it first and well this guy,
Graham Hancock has traveled all over the world taking all this.
There's footage of these incredible structures that people have made that map
out the cosmos,
that match constellations all these different societies.
Yeah,
like Macho,
Macho Picchu that like that fucking thing like you can,
how the fuck,
they don't even know how anybody got anything up there.
Like these guys got these giant fucking stones up there where there's no air and
they built these incredible structures many,
many,
many thousands of years ago.
Like they have no idea when and they think that it might've even been at a time
where water was up there.
Like it's,
it's,
it's fucking nutty,
man.
When you,
when you really find out how much of these ancient structures in ancient,
ancient civilizations,
how much evidence there is for it,
but when they start bringing this stuff up,
stuff up to conventional archeologists,
they always said,
well,
where's the evidence for these cultures?
Like that's what they said about John Anthony West when they brought up the
water erosion marks on the Sphinx.
You familiar with all that?
The water erosion on the Sphinx is due to thousands of years of rainfall.
The problem with that is the last time there was rainfall in the Nile Valley,
it was like 7,000 BC.
Yeah.
So that,
that puts it like way,
way,
way out,
dates it way past what we think of as Egypt and civilization.
Egyptian civilization,
we think of around like two thousand three thousand BC.
There's,
they're talking like 7,000,
4,000 years earlier than that.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
this is a pretty incredible shit.
So the,
these,
these guys have discovered all these different things that point to the fact
that it's much more likely that there was a far older civilization that
disappeared.
And so the archeologists are all like,
where's the evidence for this civilization?
What does fucking right there?
What else is going to be left?
What else is going to be left after 10,000 years?
Man,
you're going to get some stone that's a car would dissolve into the earth.
A building we fall apart and crumble.
You all,
everything has to be made at a stone.
That's the only shift that's going to survive.
They don't what about wondering?
But you know,
when they first found the sphinx and the,
the,
theF and I forget which fucking pharaoh they attribute it to through the guy
who,
uh,
supposedly they think built the Sphinx,
but it's in the,
the,
the hieroglyphs.
It literally says that he was told in a dream that if he uncovered this fakes,
he would go on to rule Egypt,
hit an uncovered.
You know why?
Because it was covered in fucking sand.
They had actively dig it out of the sand.
It was up to its head in sand.
Not only that,
the head has been altered,
like they know that the head used to be far larger and was much more likely the
head of a lion and then some ferals like I don't want that land.
I'm on a mat face up there bitch.
And so that's when they put his face up there and more likely it was one of the
African Pharaohs because he has a face of a noob Ian,
the Nubians conquered Egypt in the end of the Egyptian empire when everything
felt shit.
Yeah,
the,
the Nubians conquered and they,
they're pharaohs were much more African looking yet there's a,
the point is where we're both saying is there's way,
way old.
It just,
Graham Hancock guy's a fucking genius man.
And his,
his books are brilliant on this shit and he has his wife's a photographer.
So he has these incredible photographs of all these different things from all
over the world and it will absolutely convince you that they're at least this
should be considered as an option and it's not right now.
Right now,
everybody wants to think that everything they've been taught in school and
everything they're teaching their students right now is the information and it's
very difficult to get them to relook at shit.
These motherfuckers that won't look at the Sphinx,
I mean that there's water erosion.
Every single geologist who looks at that says this is water erosion from
thousands of years of rainfall,
and then they have all these other guys that are like,
no,
it can't be.
It's impossible.
It's never been a problem for me imagining that we're super or a Superbowl,
but for them they've been teaching this shit.
There've been teaching Tut Moses the third did this at this time and he built
this pyramid and you know,
they don't know though that the fucking [inaudible].
They really don't know.
It's,
it's,
it's guesswork.
There's a shit load of guesswork.
Yeah.
That's always really amazing to me.
When archeologists get very specific about something that was a really long time
and he said to his troops,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
I had to fuck.
Do you know what he said?
Barely.
Remember what I ate yesterday.
Lunch.
Exactly.
How are you fucking day?
How are you diagnosing this shit?
It's impossible to talk about this.
When I talk about on stage,
when I talk about how little we know about human beings,
if I'm in a club that it has like 200 people in it,
I'll say,
you know,
here's 200 of us right here.
What re representative,
we lived our entire lives,
birth to death and we added them all together.
We represent 20,000 years just us,
just the lives of 200 people.
If you add them all together,
birth to death,
that's 20 fucking thousand years.
That's way more than we know about human history.
Way,
way,
way more according to like conventional teaching or conventional a thought.
W W W like 20,000 years ago we were basically caveman,
right?
I mean we board animal skins and shit.
Like when they find those frozen dudes.
How old those dudes?
I have no idea.
30,000 years ago wearing skins and shit and throwing spears rock tips,
like that's as good as it got back then.
20,000 years.
Just 200 people's lives.
That's incredible,
man.
Well,
do you buy into this stuff that we came from Mars?
No.
I don't buy into any of the Mars imagery.
I don't.
You know,
I see all that Richard Hoagland documentary.
I see all these guys talking about it and you know what I say?
I see a bunch of guys who are trying to find a bunch of shit that is not
necessarily there.
You're making connections with this rock to that rock and you're using this
fucking really fuzzy geometry to describe the rate the regions.
There's some interesting structures there.
There's some interesting structures that may or may not have one point in time
been been a building,
but it's up for debate.
I think it,
it started off as the lightning bolt hitting the plasma is storks look,
it's very possible.
The storks Brian,
we're talking about for this story.
It's very possible that life existed on Mars.
It's very possible.
It's very possible that if you think about the fact that life exists has existed
on earth for billions of years,
right,
okay.
And we know that at one point in time,
you know there was lizards running shit and it was a tropical jungle and there's
dinosaurs everywhere.
And we didn't evolve until all those were wiped off the face of the planet,
right?
According to Eddie Griffin,
they weren't not wiped out the planet.
They went underground and learned to shape shift.
Please tell me he didn't say that on stage.
He didn't say it on stage.
He told it to me buying the comedies.
Has He ever told you that?
How Bruce Lee died story now Bruce Lee fun a thousand niggas
like he was standing there and he took about 900 of them out until one finally
got the deaf touch on his ass.
Fuck and death.
He will,
he will,
he will tell a fucking a tail.
Eddie Griffin would be the perfect guy to hang out with drunk and a pool hall.
I'm like a Friday night and he's talking shit.
That's his best kind of humor,
man.
Just crazy stories in fucking hilarious and he makes,
he says,
well,
it's funny,
right?
Talented Guy,
man.
He told me that was the first time I'd heard the reptilian theory when you told
it to me.
He said he was so filled with passion and the truth of it,
that it was like an eerie moment and it's not so crazy.
Always really hip,
not he hypnotized crowds,
man.
I,
I saw him.
He was very charismatic even though he was crazy.
I saw him do like two and a half hours at the comedy store wines and at the end
of his show,
the crowd got up and surge toward 10.
All,
we're trying to touch him like they were like,
he would,
he had hypnotize the entire series.
Yes.
Especially if you get really dumb,
dumb people in there.
Ooh.
He'll get,
um,
you know,
it was him.
He'll get him good.
You know?
He said once,
he said,
what a lot of people don't know is that the twin towers below them was Fort Knox
where all the gold was kept and the trains kept running 24 hours a day.
Yeah,
like what?
What are you talking about?
That there's a gold underneath.
There's gold underneath the twin towers and the trains or,
Hey,
rob,
what do I know?
This is still shit store a lot.
I would go see him.
I don't,
I don't know.
I saw,
I saw him at the store once,
but I don't have a friendly guy too,
man.
I'm always always happy to see that guy.
He's really cool.
He's a very talented guy,
man.
He's always been really crazy and everything,
but he's very talented.
He had a funny fucking joke about the dude who invented the telephone.
He goes,
he goes,
Alexander Graham Bell had to be on coke.
Who the fuck gets so high?
Do you like,
I want to talk to somebody who isn't even here.
That's a great joke.
That's one of my favorite all time jokes,
especially in that voice.
That's one of those jokes where you go,
damn,
I wish I thought that one.
I know,
isn't it kind of like,
there's two kinds of jokes.
There's jokes are like,
man,
that joke sucks.
And then there's jokes.
They're like,
man,
why didn't I think of that?
There's no,
well,
you know what really always like humbles me when I see a dude who can make jokes
out of shit there,
I probably would have dropped,
you know who impresses me with that Patton Oswald Patent.
We'll go on this killer five minute bit about a fucking bottle of water.
You know what I'm saying?
He'll like any premise health,
find it and squeeze the funny out of it.
And I always got,
damn.
That dude is like,
he knows how to like really right?
Like uh,
even for like obscure Shit that you wouldn't think would be funny.
And he does the old trick where he makes it seem like the easiest fucking thing
and the planet.
It makes it seem like it's just not comfortable.
It's comfortable,
easy.
It just happens that brilliant jokes are always a few people like that.
It's awesome to watch,
man.
Don't you still want like watching stand up?
Well,
I feel the most fun.
Right.
Do you ever get it?
You know,
if you ever get stuck or get stand up block and all you gotta do is watch the
great comics and then it'll give you inspiration to work on more jokes.
Yeah.
Man.
I'm mom used to have a puppet Dunkin.
Do you still do the Little Hobo?
I don't do it anymore.
He got stolen.
Did you hear about this Joe?
If someone stole little Hobo,
Hobo got stolen in San Jose,
who stole him?
If I knew that then somebody's stolen from like,
if I knew that I'd be in jail.
Well
Dunkin used to have this,
a little puppet that used to bring on stage that was like satanic and it was
very funny,
the funniest bit he used to do this thing where the puppet had killed his
grandfather up.
It was channeling Satan Demon.
It was crazy.
Great man.
So did you leave little Hobo in the lobby and then somebody stole it or
something?
What happened?
Well,
it's an interesting story.
I,
um,
it had,
the weird thing is I had been up in Nevada city at a Oh,
a little film comedy fest and you were saying you loved it up there in Nevada
city city's amazing.
Where is it exactly?
It's like it's north of Sacramento and I'm not really sure about how the pot
manufacturer and distribution works,
but I know that Nevada city plays a pretty important role in that.
It's like there,
it's like a big,
it's like a big part of their economy and,
and how do I know this?
I'll tell ya,
I was buying a Burrito from a hippie and he was commenting on how he likes the
festival because it's almost the business picks up to almost the level is when
the cutters are in town.
And I was like,
Whoa,
Holy Shit.
You guys have a cycle based on the sheer harvesting the crops and stuff.
So in Nevada city is also the Yuba river runs through it in Nevada.
Want to live there though,
man,
there's too many creeps.
I would say especially right now with the climate,
it's not like it's a legitimate marijuana factory that's,
you know,
everybody gets dental insurance and shit and they all worked.
Their community's happy.
That's not what's going on.
It's most of these guys were selling illegal shit.
Well,
here's the thing.
This is,
this was the really fascinating thing that someone there said to me,
they said they don't want in November,
they don't want pot to get legal because it's going to crash their economy.
It's so crazy.
That's crazy.
Cause that saying,
you know,
I would,
I'm more important than the cost.
Yeah.
Let's just put people,
I can just,
I can't adjust.
No,
it's saying I'm okay with people going to jail every,
yeah.
I can buy more hummus.
That's so douchey.
That has douchey.
That's the most fucked up thing and I didn't think of it until I walked off.
I would have said something,
but yeah,
it was really,
yeah,
I've heard the argument,
I've heard the argument from a few people,
but there's some people that are just contrarians and they just want to argue
about anything in a matter of what you bring up.
If they didn't think of it first,
they'll come up with the opposing point of view.
Oh,
I hate those people.
So those are,
those are conversation vampires.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a bunch of people that every conversation they have is just some sort of
an act where they want you to walk away impressed,
you know?
I mean,
there's a lot of people there.
Oh yeah.
You know,
they're not listening to a God damn thing you're saying.
They just want to argue it's a lot of Douche bags,
like angry at that very annoying man because it's not a real conversation.
You just want to throttle up.
It's like we're,
we're only having this conversation because you're insecure and fucked up a lot
of comics that are like that.
A lot of comics,
a lot of common,
no matter,
no,
not most of them,
but there's quite a few.
There's quite a few that are looking for arguments.
Yeah.
Oh God.
That year beaters where they just get in and just start.
You gave me that word.
I used that word so fucking nice dude.
He is just Joe D.
That's a funny word.
Joe is getting in their beat.
Novia mother.
He would say that Joe Diaz has the best fucking lines but everything and no
matter what it is,
well he's the best man.
I walk on ice,
I might as well dance.
You know what I'm saying?
If you,
you know how you could become a fucking billionaire if you could make a joke
Diaz application where you could have Joe Diaz in her phone.
No.
You know how to
billionaire is if Joe Diaz let me do him in a cartoon,
Withdraw Draw Joey Diaz cartoon about this Jelly guy goes around and smacking
people and talking to them.
Yeah.
I want to Joey Diaz soundboard though.
I want one that just goes,
oh no,
really
good show.
A Joey Diaz show where he gives like real logic to high school kids where Joey
Diaz like high school kids will come to him for lessons about life.
And so he deals with breakdown.
Let me tell you about the first time I ate ass.
Listen,
get over it.
You gotta eat ass?
No,
he's got four Jack Jacket Cokes.
You written that cocksucker it's a part of it sounds so lost out.
It's part of his parole as part of its community service.
Okay,
so will you do with college college kids,
right?
Yeah.
You have to sign some papers.
I was thinking 18 but you're right.
High School isn't really 18 college is 18 like he comes to their orientation and
gives a speech about college.
Oh robot cock sucker.
Trust me.
Can't even take care of yourself.
Cox Stock.
You're going to raise a baby still but we can film them a little house on the
prairie.
We could film a month ago.
Film them separately like film,
just a Joey Diaz like screaming at nothing and then have like a scary clown and
to put,
you know with the little girl.
Just had the girl crying the whole time.
He's the scary clown and just put the two together,
you know,
take out the clown and it's put Joey.
Joey Diaz
is almost any situation you put them in.
It's always going to be funny.
Yes.
There's always going to be a swirl of comedy.
Okay.
That video you used to do a fuel TV.
Do you still do stupid face?
No.
There was one with Joey Diaz had the,
he edited Joy Diaz on top of a,
what was it like a,
he was like a little micro fisherman or something like,
yeah,
Galaxy Galaxy cabinet is a it.
He was a,
he was a villain that lived in then it's a long weird lives in someone's head or
something and someone's neck on a little boat and he was called the fishermen.
That's the best one.
You can find it on youtube or on your website or some best thing you've ever
done in my opinion,
when you've done a lot of great stuff.
But my one of my favorites,
cause I did not know it was you until I started watching it was drunk history
when you talked about Nikola Tesla.
First of all,
I loved it because you and I are both huge Tesla fans and we've talked so many
times about how fascinating that guy was.
But the fact that you did that video where he got super,
super fucking drunk or just going off,
what did you say?
Well can we play that because it's great you played drunk history because it's
really fucking brilliant.
It's episode two,
right?
Um,
and if you go online,
if you want to watch it online,
look for a trunk history.
What on Youtube?
Trust me.
Drunk history.
Tesla.
Just look under Duncan Trussell Two d u n t a.
N Trussell is t r U.
S.
S e l.
L.
And it's fucking hilarious.
So we're going to play the audio of it.
But you watched watched the video of it too because John see Riley's in it and
he plays Tesla,
right?
Sprinkle ever.
Yeah.
John C.
Reilly Voice Tesla and Crispin Glover Place Edison.
It's fucking brilliant.
Awesome.
How cool was it to have shit you did and have fucking John C.
Reilly doing your words cause I was looking at,
I was like,
wow,
that's what I'd look like if I could act.
You can act to acting is just about getting comfortable.
You are very good at committing to weird shit.
You remember that one time that we did this weird backstage thing or Brian was
filming it?
We were pretending like we were going to film a documentary here.
Remember that?
Yeah.
That was fun man.
But I'll tell you this,
acting,
it's not,
is this it right here?
Yeah.
Here's drunk history with Duncan Trussell and how drunk were you when you did
this?
Blacked out trunk or what did you drink?
Absent and and a six
pack of beer.
Oh my God.
How much absent half a bottle of it.
Yeah.
That stuff gets you so weird that it died.
Really?
Nicoletta test.
Oh my God.
The father of Western technology.
Oh more everything we know is like modern electricity.
Tesla invented that.
You also have it in wireless technology.
Invented the radio.
Supposedly one day he was taking a walk in a park and he suddenly experienced
this tremendous flood light and he saw in his mind the perfect blueprint of an
engine that would create something called alternating current.
And that was an is like I have to go to the United States.
I mean,
listen Amit,
so Tesla sail across the ocean found that as in who at the time was like the
king of Electricity Edison.
It was like,
all right,
well I guess you,
you can work for me.
And his job was like,
his job was digging ditches for Edison
and from this guy Westing house.
It's like gave him money to start like working on his idea of alternating
current.
So Edison didn't like the idea of alternating current because he owned all the
patents on direct.
Current alternating current was the only two jobs.
I can't do it.
I'm going to start a few things.
Did you get all the details right?
Even though you were so won the contract to supply to all the electricity to the
world's fair and this pissed Edison off.
He was like,
fuck this.
Uh,
alternating current is bad,
alternating current will only caused massive debt.
And so he started this campaign to approve the alternating current was like the
worst current you could use.
What he did is EBN to like publicly electric cute animals.
Edison wasn't asshole.
He was like taking like sheep and mean like look what happens when the sheep
touches the alternating current.
Oh,
I blew it gets electrocuted.
Look what happens when a cow comes in contact with Oswald in current.
It dies.
Tesla was horrified and he'd be like,
this is,
I am inventing electricity and you look like an ass hole because you fucking
idiot
can do it.
Good night.
Thank you everyone.
Tesla uh,
discovered the energy to run the world's fair.
And at that moment Tesla became an international figure,
worshiped by everyone.
So Tesla has like a laboratory like mark twain and like everybody who was famous
in the world come to the laboratory.
Do we like do things like make electricity shoot around his body?
People will be watching,
like,
look at him,
he's on fire.
Mark Twain will be there crying.
And then new id add was that I don't think you necessarily need to have like
power plants for there to be electricity.
I think that you can take away tricity from the air.
This was directly opposed to uh oh.
Of Capitalist Society.
So he was basically ostracized from society.
I did
this come out of my body.
It's their visas.
There's Tine Applebee's is okay.
I know I chewed it and he went crazy,
you know.
But his greatest pleasure as he was getting old was feeding pigeons and he fell
in love with a specific patient.
What's going on.
Okay.
Brian Internet just stopped.
Did it?
Yeah,
it's not loading up the whole video.
Yeah.
Oh okay.
Well they get watch.
All right.
Just go on youtube anyway.
Tesla.
Why?
Well I think that was pretty much the gist of it.
But how did,
did you,
did you have to study for that?
Yeah,
I read a book on Tesla and I watched a documentary on Tesla so I had all my
facts straight.
But,
but you knew the whole story beforehand cause we've talked about it and many
times both.
I didn't know the extent of it until I,
until,
because I knew enough about it to know it would be a cool drunk history and I'm
friends with the guy who does that,
Derek waters and I was like,
you got to let me do Tesla.
You know Tesla was another one who believed he was in communication with
feelings with aliens.
Yeah.
But see this is a,
he believed he was receiving signals.
Right.
Here's an interesting point that I think we should talk about because you know,
you can use the term aliens or whatever,
but where do your jokes come from?
Yeah,
sure.
The ether.
I,
I've always said that at my most creative,
I'm merely a passenger.
I'm watching it all come out and I just keep my own bullshit from getting in the
way of myself from getting in the way of the idea.
Like last night,
like I was a in the middle of the writing and this is,
you know,
when I'm especially like late at night,
I always find like reasons to get distracted sometimes when I'm writing.
So I'm in the middle of writing and while I am thinking about something I think,
wow,
look at all this crazy shit I wrote.
Wow.
Where is this all coming from?
Like Austin,
it's me,
you know,
thinking like in,
in like this list ego way.
Look at all of the work you've done,
look at all those.
And then the idea,
whatever I had slipped out of my head,
it was just like,
hey stupid.
You know,
it's not about you,
not me.
It's not about you getting any accolades.
Are you patting yourself on the back for fucking sitting in front of a computer,
punch in keyboard for five minutes or five hours it,
what did it,
what it's about is what comes out.
That's what it's about.
It's about the final result,
the final product.
And when that's what you're thinking about,
it's really not even you.
It's like it's just coming out of the air.
Yeah.
In fact,
the,
yeah,
the less you that's involved,
the better.
It's better to,
and that's a hard,
it's the hardest thing because it's like trying to catch those thoughts are
trying to put yourself in the right position where those thought,
where you're catching them in the statics gone.
It's fucking hard,
man.
In fact,
cause you can't force it.
And that's the zen thing.
Yeah.
If you try to catch it,
it runs away from you.
And if you don't try to catch it,
that's when the thoughts start popping into your head.
And usually it's like happening at times when you're not expecting it.
You're not,
you can't,
you can't make it happen.
Do you ever read the war of art?
Uh,
yeah.
As a matter of fact,
yes.
Yes,
I have.
Yeah.
I love that.
But
I give it to people.
Do you have a copy of it?
I do.
The thank you.
Yeah.
I'll give it to people.
They don't have it because it's such a fucking amazing book when it comes to
writing.
But that dude,
Steven Pressfield,
he talks a lot very openly about the idea of a muse.
Yeah.
Know that like he shows up and does his work and the Muse shows up and gives
them,
the idea is,
I mean that's like this ancient idea in ancient thought,
but it really does feel like it's something else besides you.
Well,
you know the,
we were talking about this earlier.
Um,
so John Lilly,
the father of the flotation tank,
um,
he sort of breaking,
he openly says he had contact with extra dimensional beings.
So he used to shoot ketamine and climb into the tank.
He used to jab himself in the leg intramuscularly with ketamine.
A fucking cat tranquilizer.
Yeah.
Is that what it's for?
Cats.
What does ketamine?
Uh,
I thought courses,
it's for cats.
Horses.
I always heard it was cat and he would,
uh,
he would fucking go for a trip.
They say ketamine is supposed to be one of the weirdest psychedelic experiences.
Mckenna had a very interesting way of describing it.
He said Ketamine is fairly recent as far as like fairly new as far as like human
use.
And you know,
mushrooms are around for thousands and thousands of years document to human use.
He said,
when you take a mushroom trip,
one of the things that you're taking the trip is the idea that you're in.
You were embedding yourself in all the other trips that happened with all the
other mushrooms before.
Like you,
you engage in one big,
joyous,
you know,
interconnected experience.
And it's one of the reasons why mushrooms,
you know,
it's like,
it's such as powerful,
incredible experience.
Like you're having the experience of everyone who's ever had mushrooms,
right?
Whereas with Ketamine,
he said ketamine is like,
like an empty office building.
I must have not did enough fucking weird because that's not what it was for me.
When you're talking about Special K,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
You have to shoot it.
Oh,
well you can snort it,
but if you want to see the aliens,
the Eh,
to
me it was the exact opposite.
It wasn't like hallucinating.
It was just like,
oh,
I woke up to stern.
You know,
you can watch youtube videos of people on it.
I've got ketamine.
Ketamine is not one that went really down with,
I wouldn't really be done with trying anything.
I have to shoot in my fucking leg with a horse needle.
No.
Duncan trust was going to go for a piss.
This is the docking weak bladder.
Trussell
that'd be right back.
Right after he urinates lucky it's in the same room.
We don't,
we don't have to miss him for long.
Yes.
I've never tried ketamine,
man.
I've never tried anything that you can get addicted to.
And I heard you can get addicted to ketamine except alcohol.
Obviously Caffeine,
caffeine,
vitamins,
vitamins are healthy even though you're pretty addicted to them.
Um,
I do know that if I don't take them,
I don't feel as good.
Right.
That's,
that's definitely,
you're addicted to them.
You're addicted.
It makes you healthy.
Maybe you addicted to sleep.
Shut the fuck up.
Look at that.
Oversleeping yeah.
So what have you done?
If you've done ketamine,
you started it.
Yeah.
How much did you do,
do you know?
Uh,
I don't remember quite a lot.
Hey,
a couple lines.
How long were the alarm?
So I got an instinct.
She don't even know,
like a CD size,
you know,
crazy.
Or people in drugs,
they just go snort.
And something.
They're not measuring it.
I don't know.
The dose is stupid young kid.
The only reason I did it because I was on acid and I'm cause I'm thinking right.
Oh you kidding.
Well you already know.
You kidding.
Okay,
so you've done that.
And what other like harsh stuff you tried crack,
right?
Nah He didn't.
I know this guy looks like me.
Not allegedly.
Might've done this guy that looks like you that allegedly might've small crack.
What did he say about it?
It's,
it's just like doing cocaine kind of.
It makes you feel kind of,
I don't know.
I had to such a gross smell that to me it was just kind of like I focused,
focused my all my shit on that smell and just like being like gross,
gross feeling.
DMT has a funky smell to DMT.
Sounds like it smells like something you should not be smoking.
Right.
But then the aliens come and take you away.
Yeah.
I think the coolest shit was definitely ecstasy and that was handy.
Flipping where you do acid and ecstasy.
Dangerous man.
When you fuck can't find drugs like that.
You don't know the exact results of the,
the,
the two of them together.
That can be funky,
man.
So we're chicken happen.
Yeah.
Makenna told the story about,
uh,
doing,
I think he did
a lot of whippets have,
if you don't whip,
it's Joe.
Have you done whippets before?
Yes,
I did whip.
It's when I worked at Newport creamery,
but I found them to be quite weak.
I didn't like it.
Did you have like silver round your lips and they found you in the freezer?
No.
You know,
we worked at a creamery and they had those big whip cream things.
It's all,
you could get high off those buying by the case and get the crackers with the
balloons,
you know,
and just sit there.
I only did it once.
I did it once and gave me like a head rush.
I didn't like it.
I love it.
Yeah.
Duncan,
you love it.
Don't,
yeah.
How do you not like women?
I know you gotta love whippets.
It'd be correct man.
Yes,
brother didn't like it.
They superheat Unicorns,
turn it into nitric oxide.
I remembered
there was a way to do a whippet where you attached it to a bong somehow.
So the whip,
it was taking a bong hit,
I think it's like you pull it,
you put it in and then you put it on the end about
combining drugs.
Before I forgot was that Mckenna told a story once of taking.
He took um,
uh,
Iowasca and he took a mushrooms at the same time.
I think he took like he took an Mao inhibitor and mushrooms.
It might've been that,
it might've been that he took an Mao and hit him.
Like he took harming and he took mushrooms at the same time and he said it just
fucked him up to the point where he was watching his memory dissolve inside of
his brain and getting chewed up.
Like in the gears of a machine like irreplaceably he knew what he would never
get these thoughts and ideas back.
I had just took him like the lungs time to feel safe that he was really at one
point in time the trip convinced that this is it.
You are never coming back from this like you've gone so deep you're never coming
home.
You know what that reminds me of?
This is a,
this is fascinating cause I thought of this recently.
So the inventor of Lsd,
Albert Hoffman,
he the first,
he was the first person to take Lsd,
took it in the laboratory and when he took it,
you know,
they call it bicycle date,
right.
You know that whole story.
Do you call it bicycle day?
Yeah.
You know,
the day LSD was invented,
the bicycle day because he took anyone for riding his bike and he looked down as
flying over the mountains and that started the 60s well it was the 40 so it was
a little while,
but so anyway,
he,
when he took that Lsd,
he took a huge dose and he did not know that it would stop.
Like if you've ever taken LSD and you're having like maybe not the best trip,
there's always a friend nearby,
it'd be like,
don't worry,
you'll be fine.
A couple hours Hoffman,
he didn't have that.
He couldn't put on any pink Floyd.
There is no tie dyes to stare at.
There was just him in bed with his wife giving him milk.
They were giving him milk and he said he was being attacked by demons and his
bed.
The first person that ever did anything psychedelic like that or a first
experience like that when there's no information,
must've been so terrified.
The worst trip every time.
Cause someone will find a new one because this is the thing I was thinking,
you know the amazing story of how Di Dmt or Iowa Ska comes from.
Like you've told me this,
a zillion different herbs in the jungle and how the fuck did someone figure that
out?
This is what I think,
you know,
most of the planet is ocean.
So there's gotta be psychedelic starfish.
There's gotta be some kind of crazy mix of shit that someone's going to find and
take and there's going to be a new psychedelic drug.
I'm not saying it's going to come from the seat,
but there's going to be a new,
there's going to be a new
drug that comes out eventually as the same impact.
The Elliot snorting Cmo?
I really think so.
I hope so.
Give her a snort stats.
Well,
the thing is that everything that comes up,
they throw the water on it.
Everything.
You know,
Salvia,
there's no reason to make Salvia illegal.
No one's died of Salvia ever pulling it off the shelf.
Any illegal why?
Yeah,
because the retarded internet videos it produces.
Brian did one,
right?
There's just too,
man,
I'm not yours.
You're a Salvy.
Videos are great.
I'm telling you about all the other ones.
I just can't stand watching someone turned themselves into what someone with Ms.
It's the worst.
It's not exciting watching co like Brittany Spears videos.
I would like TMZ.
You still like car accident when a watch?
Well sort of,
but for someone,
okay,
let's just say this is,
we are,
you know,
men who have lived longer than others and we have experienced more than others.
But if you're living in fucking Indiana and you're 17 years old and you,
you know,
your friend just did Salvia and you're going to watch a video and he told you
changed his fucking life and he's reexamining the way it looks at the world.
And,
and you watched that video.
I mean,
that can be kind of a trip.
And so we're looking at it like saying like,
all these morons are doing this,
but you know,
from your point of view,
they're more on.
She may let me just say,
I don't think there are,
a lot of them are morons.
Let's be real.
Okay,
they're morons.
But
here's the thing though,
you know,
I was a moron at God.
Thank God there was no youtube when I was doing drugs for the first time,
you know?
But,
um,
fuck yeah.
But here's the thing,
the problem with,
when I see those videos inevitably,
here's what you'll see in the background outside of yours.
You'll,
what you'll see in the background is a baby crib or,
um,
you'll hear a,
they're listening to this.
Uh,
the x box is on full blast.
Or like the opposite things that you would want to have in the background is
you're trying to access a psychedelic state are happening because these kids,
they don't know how to take the psychedelics.
You've got to heat the oils.
I just hate because there's,
we need to Sharmane.
Yeah,
it's really a fucking a travesty that we don't have people that have experienced
these things that are like,
like reputable,
you know,
there'd be some sleazy Shama and they're just trying to get their deck socks,
some creepy dudes,
which there are white,
which there are now.
There's a lot of those dudes out there now in the psychedelic community that are
like kind of like fucking fake wise man is.
There's a lot of fake wise.
Yeah.
It,
there's a lot of people that are trying,
but you know,
half of them are sake.
You know,
how about the old when someone's telling you about some deep everything and then
it's like cigarette.
So many of them.
Yeah.
So fucking many of them.
I swear to God,
Dude,
I was in front of the Improv and the guy started telling me about how dangerous
Kim trails were fucking cigarette mark.
It's like,
dude,
you're sucking poisonous gas intentionally in your mouth.
Why are you worried about,
can worry about chem trails for you.
What you're doing is 10 times worse making chem trails.
Could you imagine if babies could smoke cigarettes if baby's had cigarette smoke
pumped to the lungs the way this guy,
I think he should have channel trails are bad.
If Kim Charles or really that bad.
There's really a bad for you.
Yeah.
What he's doing.
I mean it's not as bad as cigarettes are.
Not as bad.
No.
I pointed it out fucking way worse,
man.
He felt bad about it.
Yeah.
You know babies are doing fine.
Getting blasted by chem trails.
Okay.
What I'm saying is if you gave baby cigarettes they'd be fucked.
Oh yeah.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
You don't seem a lot of fucking,
yeah,
you don't see like angry babies.
You do though.
If you watch him videos from Thailand,
two year old from Thailand smoking cigarettes thing ever.
I'm sorry,
your kids smoking as cute as far as trends.
They don't give a fuck over there.
And it's cute.
It's adorable.
I don't know why,
but there's something at door will hit,
gets mad when he doesn't get a cigarettes.
Throws temper tantrums.
That's a freaks.
Yeah.
When you're two or three and whenever he is,
you've got no self control.
Nicotine,
Fritz by both of you guys have kicked cigarettes.
Brian,
you're back on the cigarettes,
right?
Yeah.
For a couple weeks ago.
Okay,
so I've never done the cigarettes.
Tell me,
what is the pole?
Why is it so difficult to quit?
What is it?
Well,
it's one of the most addictive substances on the planet according to scientists.
It's fucking horrible.
Here's the airwon.
So you're hooked on here.
So they say that's this thing.
They always said,
you're right.
Let's say you're an ex heroin addict,
right?
And you're in the program and you're going to Naa and you're working on your
life,
but heroin's legal,
right?
So every time you go out in public and walk to go get your groceries,
there's a chance that when you go into the grocery store,
there's a guy with a belt around his arms shooting up before he goes to get
middle and deep.
So just everywhere you go,
yeah,
you're getting triggered.
W with cigarettes,
it's exact.
It's like with cigarettes,
you're hooked on the most addictive substance,
but everywhere you go there's going to be a couple of people smoking,
triggering that addiction and forcing you back into the cycle ends.
Right.
Reaction is you're not going to die for having that one cigarette.
You're going to actually feel relaxed and exactly what you want.
You know,
you're not going to be like,
I had a cigarette and I had a heart attack and died.
You know?
It's incredible.
It's incredible how widespread it is.
It's mostly for stress,
you know?
And it's mostly for relaxation.
It's just like any drug,
but very mild compared to every other.
Yeah.
I was very lucky that I had friends when I was in high school that had already
started smoking cigarettes that already were hooked and I was like,
this is incredible.
They're 17 years old and they're hooked on cigarettes.
This is just fucking insane.
And so I made sure that I,
I never did it.
I tried to,
I think I tried it once.
I tried a cigarette at a party when I was like 15 I didn't like it.
It was disgusting.
But my point is like if you see somebody smoking cigarettes,
man,
the smoking cigarettes is grows.
You ever see someone that that's a heroine guy?
Yo,
you ever known anybody that's got a heroin problems?
I have never known.
Well,
I guess I have known a heroin junkie here and there,
but I've never been close with them.
Have you ever been around someone?
Right,
right after they did it?
No.
There's this guy named buffalo bill when I used to play pool and white plains
executive billiards in white plains,
New York.
There was a lot of action there.
A lot of gambling that place you stay up till like four or five o'clock in the
morning.
The guy owned it,
his name is Guy Hamilton is cool motherfucker.
His actual name was guy as a reader,
but he was a professional piano player and he thought Aza reedy sounded to
Guinea.
So I went with Guy Hamilton.
I think it sounds more professional.
Anyway,
they used to have these,
a tremendous pool matches
that would go on due to bet thousands and thousands of dollars and people would
bet in the stands.
I mean it was some of the most fun times of my life were watching people gamble
and there was this one guy he used to come into play.
There was a dude named George the Greek.
There was this local house guy that had a ton of money and he'd like to bet
high,
he would always fuck it.
Come on you cock sucker.
You got no hot,
you bet.
5,000 and he always wanted a bed guys.
And so it guys would come in from out of state to play him.
And this dude,
Buffalo Bill,
otherwise known as water dog,
that was his other nickname.
And He,
uh,
he was a heroin junkie.
And what would happen is he would shoot heroin and then he'd come out of the
bathroom and sit in a seat like this for half an hour.
I mean,
like this like,
sorry,
now pause,
limp like a,
like the double gay limp thing.
And you sit there and his head where like half.
And then he would get up after like 25 minutes of that,
he would get up and start fucking Fairen balls into the hole with no fear.
Really could not miss.
Wow.
Could not miss.
He was one of the best players I've ever seen play.
And he was blasted out of his fucking mind on heroin.
I watched him run a hundred balls.
He was playing straight pool for it was,
I don't remember the number,
but it was always the several thousands of dollars.
He was playing a game straight pool.
The dude ran a hundred balls and out on a table with these tiny ass pockets.
The pockets were not even four inches.
It was like three and three quarter inches.
Standard is five inches.
The pros plan,
four and a half.
These are like three and three quarter.
They were tiny ass and if you didn't hit the ball perfect,
it would jar in the pocket and drive you fucking crazy.
This dude with a fire them through the fucking meat of the pocket,
like the pocket was a swimming pool and he was rolling a golf ball into it.
He was a fucking master and there's babies walking around the scene on heroin,
black dead rattle snake eyes.
He might as well have been a fucking shark.
His ibes were dead.
He was just heroin to the gills,
to the gills.
You'd look at him,
you'd saw no one in there.
You saw no one in there,
but he knew the rules are straight pool and he'd be fucking set up that break
shot,
smash that rack and be perfect on every ball.
It was infuriating and Georgia Greek would get crazy because he knew the guy was
on down.
He goes,
he's on the fucking shit.
I want to win this money.
I've got to get this cock sock off the shit.
I'm not playing these fucking junkies anymore and you get crazy and he starts
yelling,
he's smoking cigarettes.
I'm going to fucking,
he's fucking junkies is fucking,
you didn't hear a word that guy was saying just firing balls in the hole.
Didn't even look up.
George is like literally yelling and screaming cause he's about to lose this
money and the guy didn't miss a ball,
just didn't even pay.
It's just something that,
you know like with heroin,
you know,
I obviously,
it seems to engender some kind of creative state and for music it's certainly
music,
but I never thought there was like I hand coordination associated with it.
No,
what it is,
no,
his eye and coordination is already,
he's been playing pool for his whole life.
This guy,
he's a water dog,
was this guy that had played all over the fucking world.
I mean he was,
he was a killer.
He was one of those dudes would come into a pool hall.
You know there's a lot of pool halls all across America where people are begging
for some guy to come in and challenged the local player cause they think fucking
Danny's playing good.
He's got some money.
We're going to spend some money.
If any fucking road guys stick to going to take the money off Danny.
Well he's one of those guys that would slip into these towns where they was.
They would,
you know what I mean?
Still do to this day.
Pool halls.
Well our real action pool hall,
those are fun fucking places if you like pool.
And the fun part is when someone comes in and wants a gamble.
So this guy would come in all dirty hair looking big,
fucking bald head,
big stupid fat face.
Didn't look healthy at all.
Lyft all fucked up and he,
you know,
he,
you guys want to planes we want to play.
And people looking at them going,
what is this guy?
A fucking hustler came in to walk.
He had this terrible cause.
Even a bad car accident.
Always heroin down,
always heroin down,
and he would just get in and just fire on people just fine when he was,
if he had his mixture right.
I've seen him fucked up before,
but he didn't have his heroin.
There was one time where he wanted me to sponsor them.
This is all back in California.
When I first moved here,
I ran into him at hard times,
billiards,
and he wanted me to put him in the tournament,
so I said,
yeah,
I'll put you in the Turner.
He goes,
I gotta get my shit to me.
Right.
I go,
you gotta get your Shit.
Okay,
we'll go get your shit.
He goes,
well,
I need a ride.
I go,
where Compton get the fuck outta here.
Like I'm not driving a Compton.
I was,
I'm on a Sitcom,
dude.
I'm not trying to drive an a Compton so you can cop heroin so he could play pool
better.
So he didn't get his heroin that day and he played like shit.
If he would have to,
you have to get his heroin perfect.
Get as mixture.
Right.
It's very talented player though,
man.
He just got unfortunately got under the grips of that shit,
but when he was on it,
man,
I didn't care.
How's he doing now he's dead.
That's the thing about heroin dudes.
They don't really last that long.
No,
that's not a healthy drug.
You know,
it's not one that you know,
but when they're on it,
man,
yes,
he come out great.
I mean there's always the question would Jimi Hendrix would,
have he been Jimmy Hendrix if it wasn't for acid,
if it was a mushrooms for you,
probably a lot better.
Can you imagine if he went off it?
Jimi Hendrix,
you imagine,
by the way,
here's the thing man,
I've got a friend who argues that that we're a tarted argument that contrarion
you would be better if you weren't on the whoever it is.
If they weren't on here and if they yeah,
worn on the mushrooms were not on acid,
they would be better and that is crap.
Where's that coming from?
Is He never done anything?
No,
he has,
but he's like a jazz person and he's like pointing out that like miles Davis was
great before he got in heroin and it doesn't look,
yeah,
but miles Davis was always smoking weed.
Elvis Presley's never didn't draw those guys smoked weed.
I guarantee you miles Davis smoked weed to per fucking jazz musicians.
Man.
It's like comics.
I mean there's a few comics,
don't smoke weed,
just a few of us,
but for the most part,
unless they have health problems,
why wouldn't you?
Oh,
Philip k Dick dedicated one of his books to all these people who had gone and
seen from a psychedelic.
Wow.
And he had a,
he had a,
I can't remember how he described it,
but the way he described it was like,
he described them as like,
I can't remember that brilliant person out there knows who it was at the end of
that awesome animated waking life style movie they did.
Um,
what did that,
what was that?
The scanner dark.
Yes.
It's like kind of like the risk involved in deciding to do psychedelics or do
whatever it is to enhance your art.
There's a certain risk involved because sometimes you aren't,
you aren't going to come back.
Sometimes like when Mckenna makes the uh,
Mao inhibitor and the whatever and his mind is getting ground up,
he,
there's a chance he might not have got some people don't make it out.
Like some people you run into them,
they at some point in their life they will probably brilliant.
They had it together,
they were there but now they're like
borderline personality or how you handle the trip and what direction you decide
to let your consciousness go into.
Yeah,
I mean there's parts in a trip where you can let go and everything can be okay
or you can fight it and your fuck.
Yeah.
I think that's also the case in real life.
I think after the experience is over,
there's,
there's an adjustment period when you have a really intense experience where you
come back to reality in regular everyday life and it seems pretty lame and it
seems fake and it seems slippery.
You know,
one of the last time I did DMT was a few years ago and I didn't do it again
because the for like a couple of weeks after the experience like life,
uh,
in my in apt way of describing it became slippery.
I felt like that the reality was very slippery.
The idea that this insanely intense,
much more powerful experience than everyday life was available that easily that
it was just three puffs away and boom,
you're in this new dimension.
That was too crazy to me.
It was really hard to to go and apply anything that I might have got from that
experience positively into regular everyday life because it made regular
everyday life seems so transparent.
It's tricky.
It's tricky because it's not useful if you can't enjoy this life.
Like the last thing you want to do is enjoy only the psychedelic world and then
you're just fucked up on a new thing every single day and you never,
you never interact with people here and it doesn't enhance here.
It doesn't enhance this consciousness,
this state
also any cause they're people who are advocates of psychedelics.
Some of them I think take a bit of a delusional approach by making it seem like
these things are always going to be safe.
You're always going to be fine.
It's like any great thing has an inherent risk.
Wow.
So you're going to be fine.
For the most part though,
are the natural ones.
You don't hear about people dying from pod or mushrooms or DMT.
You're going to die.
And I even even go crazy.
You hear the great crazy from acid crazy.
You hear from acid,
you hear,
um,
brain damage from MTMA.
I've heard that.
I've heard dude,
I think you can get brain damage from Mtma as far as going crazy from LSD.
It's like the bottom line is your brain is the organic computer,
right?
And whenever you're putting some kind of external thing and that,
that's shifting the way the operating system works and then rebooting it and
bringing it back online.
Just like any computer,
there's some chance that when that fucking program yeah,
too.
It was a big question mark in your dog.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
As well.
Microsoft word the fuck.
Yeah.
Because,
you know,
I lose loses sound.
I wish that it wasn't that way.
But if,
you know,
sometimes if you,
for example,
go look at a video of Timothy leary late in his life,
you know,
what was he like?
Did he pull pull up like a a Timothy?
We,
no,
we don't have to just describe what he's like,
he's,
he's lucid.
No,
he's,
no,
he's not lucid.
He,
he's,
he's a little little fucked up man.
Yeah.
Maybe it was always like that,
but it seems that there is some sort of neurological impact.
The vast amount of psychedelics he's done.
It's a negative neurological
well impact.
Well,
Mckenna is the,
you know,
the Great Bard of the psychedelic movement,
right?
Yeah.
And you know,
he died of a brain tumor.
Yeah.
I mean,
and he did say no.
The doctor said there's never been a case of mushrooms causing that,
but it's not just mushrooms he was doing,
he was doing,
well,
not only that,
the doctor might not have ever known anyone to take as much mushrooms,
just Mckenna.
I mean,
you're talking about a really special case.
here's a guy who took a lot of fucking psychedelics all over his life.
The guy died of a mushroom shaped tumor.
I mean literally had a tumor that shaped like a mushroom is hot and heat.
That must've been so embarrassing for him.
Like you really think so.
I headed out to Bj.
I'm no actually you actually,
it was fairly open about it and he said um,
that a a shorter,
intense life worth living.
Like if that is the cost of the experience that he's had,
it's absolutely worth.
But it's like if you are a masturbation advocate and you're like it's totally
fine,
it's healthy,
you can jerk off all the time,
it doesn't do anything and then your off brain scan and it looked like there was
a,
a tumor shape,
like a jar of Vaseline in your brain's Dick.
Yeah.
Why would it be a jar of Vaseline and
tried to get obscure fast?
You should have said like a dick.
So many other things.
It was just too obvious,
right?
Bastard.
Was Vaseline ever really a way to masturbate?
I tried to use it the other day and was like,
are you kidding?
It's not the right way.
When I was in high school and I was like,
that definitely feels better than you just using my hand,
but not worth the effort.
So I do it once.
Vaseline,
it's being gay is awful.
Massive.
And also I still have frozen in my memory.
I went to this really lonely guys apartment wine,
so it's editing something and like on his fucking desk was an open jar of
Vaseline with,
oh no,
it was a,
yeah,
you,
I forgot to clean
or he just didn't care.
He's like,
yeah,
it's my Vaseline.
That's my dip in job
growth.
I watched 'em
this incredible documentary with a,
it was a show in in the UK with Eddie Izzard.
Did you hear about it?
Marathon man.
No reason why I'm thinking about Vaseline is he,
he ran these marathons and one of the things he had to do was put like Vaseline
or you know,
some lubrication all over his sack and his balls and his dick and his nipples.
He ran some insane number of marathons in a row,
like over 40 in a row to raise money for this thing and he's not in shape and
he,
he doesn't,
didn't have a history of running and he started running marathons
and he was running.
I'm like,
he ran a thousand miles.
Wow.
He ran all around the UK,
did it in like a month.
It's fucking incredible,
man.
It's incredible because he's not even in shape.
He just did it for through sheer willpower.
I couldn't imagine if I had to run 26 fucking miles a day over and over and over
again.
I mean,
he was having all these problems.
Like today's my 11th marathon.
He gets to the fucking finish the 11th in a row,
dude,
in 10 days you ran 11 fucking marathons or in the 11 days,
rather he ran 10 marathons.
Yeah,
he can.
He kept going.
He would take a day off every now and then when they literally told him,
you can't walk today,
your feet are so fucked up.
You got blisters all,
I mean,
they were cutting blisters off and draining them with needles.
And he's wincing and then it would just run another marathon the next day.
It's fucking incredible.
Incredible.
I never would have expected it.
You know,
I always saw that guy on TV,
you know,
and he,
he had some pretty clever material and he's wearing a dress and I was like,
okay,
I guess that's his Shtick,
you know,
whatever.
What do I give a fuck?
I never really paid attention.
But after watching this documentary,
I'm like,
wow,
like that guy's a powerful motherfucker.
That was a brilliant thing.
I mean the,
the,
the fact that he was able to push himself to run some like 40 something fucking
marathons over a thousand miles.
He ran,
I think it was 1,100 miles or something crazy like that.
He ran all around the UK.
It's fucking amazing.
And he's like,
you know,
he's a fat guy who's 47 years old.
He just willed himself to do it and he's never been a competitive athlete.
Never done anything like that.
Yeah.
It really shows you where you're setting the bar in your life.
Because like yesterday I was like willed myself to carry my groceries up my
steps.
I was like,
this is pretty good.
You didn't take the elevator by his house.
Somebody had glued pubic hair to the the just the crossing button where you push
the car.
I had the president and you get pubic hair?
No,
I mean that's it.
That's it.
That is a,
I don't know how it applies but yeah,
that somebody in my neighborhood and my neighborhood is filled.
It's a hipster hive and it's like filthy hipsters.
Someone had the brilliant idea of clipping their pubic hair and using rubber
cement.
The glue it on the button.
You have to press the across the street.
Now how does the hipster community get started?
How does how to hipsters take over a neighborhood?
I know how Puerto Ricans do it.
I know how Chinese people do it.
It starts with disagree coming in with their country and then they only spend,
that goes from one language.
They meet together,
they form a community by town.
Word hipster is like a new word for like the subculture and the subculture gets
pushed basically.
It's like,
but is it really the subculture?
It is monstrously huge.
It's like the idea of alternative music.
It's not alternative when it's selling millions of copies.
So it goes,
it goes like this.
Here's the way it works.
There's,
there's like on the very fringes of society right there,
the artists,
like the real artists,
the people who are getting like alien transmissions or whatever you want to call
it,
they're getting super inspiration and they're creating amazing things.
And usually these people are not like the mainstream.
They're way different.
They're usually crazy or off or they're not as,
they're not in the same dimension that most people are.
Right,
right,
right.
Dude,
if you put this up to your mouth,
it'd be better work.
You're varying a lot cause you keep turning away from the microphone.
It's very directional.
And the people get annoyed at this shit.
Sorry,
you guys put condenser microphones up,
but then you'd hear my dogs barking and you'd hear the fucking water running.
Sounds good.
So hipster theory,
hips,
hipster theory.
You get the artist,
the art and the artists got a group of friends,
right,
right.
The group of friends are really annoying and everyone cool moves away or kind of
artists know they're kind of artists and they start imitating whoever this,
this charismatic figures.
You get that group of friends,
right?
And so that group of friends there is,
you're the first group of people that goes and moves in to the shittiest
neighborhood where the rents low,
cause they're all artists.
They don't have a lot of money right now you've got a pretty cool group of
people cause you got the guys using the weird uh,
stencils at the bought baby holding the bomb and the flowers and he lives
downtown and everyone knows he's a genius and his friends live there too.
So let's go move downtown.
So what,
maybe we'll get beaten up or mugged a couple of times,
but we'll be around Banksy though.
Super artistic.
I was living on the shitty part of time.
So then what ends up happening is you get following the group of friends and
another group of people who were friends with the friends and these are the
posers.
And then those are the people who start filling up the neighborhood.
And that's when you get a hipster neighborhood cause you get like people,
you get one really crazy guy.
I was like,
you know what,
today I'm going to dress like the front of sergeant pepper album.
I'm going to curl my mustache out and wear bell bottoms.
Oh,
what's it feel like to live in the center of the hive though?
Like is there anything like,
cause I know you watch him like through binoculars at night and study them.
So what's,
is there like it's,
it's party,
lot of parties with the Depeche mode but like backwards or do you like it?
Do you like living with all these hipsters?
I'd rather live there than West Hollywood or lived there with like with like
people who are,
who are,
you know,
taking authentic pleasure in riding the bullet saddle ranch.
I'd rather live there than like around a group of people who love Karaoke.
Yeah.
I don't like to be,
I like to live around no people.
That's what I want.
You ever thought to be suburban at all?
Have you ever thought to move to like a Burbank or it just like a more suburban
neighborhood or do you kind of like being in the know I'm,
we're looking for a place right now.
We're trying to get the fuck out of there.
We're looking for a place.
Well,
we want to move near Maman.
We want to live in that area here.
This is Mars.
Cow Is telling you
rev.
You don't even know what Mars is.
You should have live with me or come to visit me.
When I was living in Colorado,
when I was living in Colorado,
I was living on the top of a mountain 3000 feet above boulder on 150 acres,
eight miles up a dirt road into the woods.
That was,
that was Mars.
That was literally,
you would see the sky at night just filled with star.
She's incredible.
Too soon.
Move up there after a move up there.
After these Railey's start.
No,
listen man.
The probably problem up there is having babies,
having little kids up there and having a wife.
It doesn't have to drive in the snow.
If it wasn't for all that shit,
I would still be up there.
Right.
It was incredible.
It was like you're living around the most incredible artwork
that's ever been created by anything and it's natural artwork.
These mountains,
this not a painting.
It's a natural three dimensional,
gigantic,
super beautiful thing that's right in front of you all the time and it's
humbling and majestic.
And I would drive up this fucking road to the,
to the mountain,
and as you're turning and you're seeing the snow cap peaks in July,
there's fucking snow on them and it's just staggeringly beautiful.
And the sky is just crisp and clean.
There's not a hint of smog.
It's incredible.
Incredible.
If you can live in a place like that,
why the fuck wouldn't you?
But it's hard.
That's a babies and your dog gets eaten by a fucking mountain lion.
It's not easy.
I think that's the a isn't that the plot of the shining?
No.
Well,
it's kind of kind of is.
Dude was already nuts,
man.
I'm not nuts.
That's the point.
Fuck man.
By the,
yeah,
he was his.
Jeremy,
are you talking about?
I am trying.
Truth is Joe eight that means I am whiting.
Joe Ate the dog.
Actually there was no mountain lion dogs talking the book
talking to many barks while I was writing.
I got crazy.
Joe,
what are you doing?
Okay,
I have to write when everyone's asleep,
man,
don't you?
When do you write?
Can you write during the day?
I just have to be alone.
I don't feel like I get the same transmission.
I don't feel like I get the same connection to the universe.
It sounds completely retarded,
but it,
when more people are asleep,
I feel like there's less interference,
you know?
Oh,
I see.
I really,
the one of the reasons why,
and this sounds totally hippie,
you know,
go where a crystal you faggot.
It sounds like that,
but I,
one of the reasons why I like living way far away from people is it I,
I'm very sensitive to people's energy.
I'm very sensitive to people's intent and very sensitive to,
you know,
to what's going on.
And I think even if I don't want to tune that in,
I think there's a certain amount of really like low,
low,
um,
low frequency interference.
Sure.
You get from people when you're around them all the time.
Like if you're around a bunch of negative douche bags,
even if you're not interacting with them,
I think they're affecting the frequency of the environment.
Yeah.
Sounds silly now,
but it doesn't,
if you go to New York City man,
you feel the,
you feel the energy of the city.
What exactly are you feeling?
You're feeling all the fucking people,
man.
You're feeling something that's intangible
and also,
you know,
it's like,
if you think about it,
we,
we did survive when,
back in the days when Pete,
when it was common to get eaten by a tiger and stuff.
Yeah.
To be completely in tune with the tribe that you are living in.
The tribe wasn't in tune with each other.
You're dead.
Your tribe is gluing pubic hair to stop sign.
Yeah.
That's my tribe.
That's your tribe.
That's what that's around.
That's what you're around them.
Well,
I know what you're saying.
I,
I feel less influenced by like that,
that level of when the,
when it's that far away.
But it's like,
it's more like when you're the group of people that you really hang around with,
like the person you live with,
the people that you drive around with.
Those are the people who are really shaping,
you know,
your
wife or your girlfriend was the one that did that though.
We've found out that she was the one that glued the pubic hairs.
The happiest days of my life.
Like my bitches a freak.
The fuck.
Like why you want it around pubic hair.
He just got horny and crazy.
I just didn't seem like the right to not even cubic.
They're actually my butthole Harris.
Wow.
I've been collecting them for 10 years since I was 12.
Did a girl with buddle hair and have to talk to her about it.
If my girlfriend had butthole here,
you wouldn't say anything.
You just deal.
Yeah.
Whoa.
What am I going to,
I would much rather deal with anger once she had a butthole hair this way back
in the day.
And,
um,
the bottle here at poop on it.
Oh God saw it was hitting it.
Oh my God.
That was too,
I was only 21 too,
so I totally went limp.
I just could not keep it together and it was just too much.
I had guys talk about it.
No,
I don't remember what I was,
uh,
I don't remember.
I think I just just fucking made an excuse and ran out the room.
I did it.
This girl that had such so much butt hole here that sometimes you put it in like
fuck her and it would pull her whole hair.
And so you had to like push it out the way.
Really.
You useless mother fucker.
Fuck.
How dare you
tell shout something like that.
That's what he does all the time and it takes,
it's cute
how unappetizing to his movies look preview.
Every time it comes on,
everyone goes [inaudible].
People go,
oh,
get the fuck outta here.
You can only rape my mind so many times,
sir,
he's gotta change his name.
I've gone to two movies where that hit,
that preview came on and both of them had that same exact reaction.
Ah,
people are sick of that dude.
People are sick of that dude.
We've done some podcast rants already.
The fuck you m night Shama Lama Ding Dong podcast for worse.
We've already done them so we can't repeat it.
But he's one of those guys where you know there's people that have accused him
of stealing the idea for the sixth sense to apparently there was something else
that had the exact same idea and it was written very similar.
How does he keep getting money to make movies like Hollywood is filled with
retards?
Man,
they just,
he made me him.
Maybe he'll hit it again.
Proved if he gets it this time,
man,
he's back.
He's back.
Look at 6 cents.
He won the Oscar win an Oscar or something.
I think that's amazing though.
You make one good thing.
Oh,
you have to do is make one good thing and you get like seven bombs that you can
do.
Well,
he's had some that are born with that bad,
like unbreakable wasn't that bad.
I didn't enjoy it.
I mean,
I enjoyed it,
but I didn't think it was the greatest thing in the world.
But,
and then the village was kind of Goofy,
but it wasn't atrocious.
But I heard the one with Marky mark,
the plant one when the plants come alive and killer.
Right.
That was awful.
So bad.
It's so bad.
It's an unintentional comedy.
What about this new,
the new,
like what's his name?
I'm not there.
I'm still here.
Well,
the one with the guy did the prank.
He went on Letterman and kind of acted like you went.
You did Jackie.
Have you seen this?
Phoenix?
Yeah.
It's a whole two year practice he was doing.
Is it good acting crazy?
No.
I don't think everyone knew that he was doing a prayer.
I don't care.
No one was fooled.
Like everyone knew that he,
this was,
that means nothing to me.
I don't like when people pretend to be something that not unless it's brilliant.
Right.
You know,
you gotta be bore Rod.
Okay.
Yeah,
if you can do that.
That's,
that's funny to me.
But just pretending you're crazy.
Who Cares?
And is thinking,
well,
you wasted two years of your time.
Dude,
I don't care about that guy at all.
Like,
why would you even care about the great actor?
He was great.
And Johnny Cash.
I mean,
it just doesn't seem like a good premise for most people.
It's hard for a dude to do Johnny Cash in my eyes and pull it off.
I'm like,
you're going to do,
you're going to do Johnny Cash.
You're not Johnny Cash.
Why are you pretending you're Johnny Cash?
You're going to do Johnny can you got to be a bad motherfucker?
Johnny Cash.
And he did it.
He pulled it off perfectly.
I bought it.
Hook line and sinker actors.
Brilliant.
It was great.
And gladiator too.
It was fucking fantastic relationship with his sister.
That idea for that.
The prank.
I know what it came from.
It came from cocaine real.
That's a cocaine idea.
He was doing blow with,
what's his name?
Um,
they got just talk on the banks thing.
He was doing blow.
He was,
he was doing cocaine with a,
who's the guy who did the Moo?
Who produced the movie?
Colin Hanks.
Colin fuck off.
Sean Milan,
who is the guy who did it was a no idea.
Oh,
Casey Affleck.
Casey AFLAC.
Joaquim we're doing blow.
And that's a strong statement.
You just,
you just outed them.
Well,
I mean,
is that a surprise?
It just feels like a coke idea.
It feels like an IGA.
This is just purely European regulation.
This is in no way reflects the opinion of the Joe Rogan either.
What you're saying it though?
What?
So what,
so what happens now?
I don't know.
I think a lawsuit.
Well,
lawsuits happen.
I just think it's funny you said allegedly.
No you didn't.
It's my theory.
I don't know if it's true.
So why did you,
why did you think that?
Why do you think that?
Because it's an ego idea.
It's like an idea that like you think you're going to do this new brilliant,
innovative cutting edge thing and you're going to diverge away from what you're
already great at.
And then you just end up putting out this thing where no one's tricked and
everyone's mildly annoyed.
It's just,
it's like,
it's so stupid.
It's so poignant.
Just nailed it.
Just do it.
Just do what you're good at.
Don't cause this always happens.
It always happens.
Where a really great actor or some someone or do you think it's an ego thing?
Yeah,
it's an,
it's an ego thing.
Why?
Why is it an ego thing?
Because he wants to see that.
If he,
if he can pull it off because he wants to see if he can pull it up and he thinks
he's important enough or the entire country is going to,
oh my God.
Well what's happened to our dear?
Why no one cares?
You go three months down the road.
You've forgotten about the guy.
Yeah.
It's a bit disappointing because he was a good actor.
He's still a good actor to make you work with nutty and stuff.
Some
shit into his face.
I remember when he had fake cheekbones.
Oh,
is that you went nutty when money,
but they took them back.
It took him back.
Well,
I hope they take quite keen back.
Do you don't want him to lose his position and I know I love his movies.
He's a great actor.
Great actor.
What about his hip hop?
Not impressed.
Love it.
That's the only good thing about that movie is the music.
He's my new song.
Tell me what you think to today's Oh,
oh,
I seen your girl's butthole.
Do Dude,
don't just give that stuff away.
Have you copyrighted that?
A senior girls bought home.
It's really good at searching lately.
You should make a move.
I,
there's a I,
there's several people that I know in my life that I would love to do one of
those.
Wendy's had to heat things.
Just have them convinced that we're really shooting.
Yes.
A movie with them.
Totally.
Really doing a document.
If you ever seen,
I haven't seen what the city,
he's amazing.
Awesome.
Still haven't seen it.
Check it out.
So good.
The idea for people don't know is they convinced this crazy guy that he was
famous,
allegedly.
Allegedly.
Crazy.
He's crazy.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Allegedly.
Do you,
is that you really have to say that I can't get in trouble.
You don't want to hurt the flesh though.
I can get in trouble.
Frustrated it going to do with what I'm saying.
Don't be,
you know,
very,
I'm just very concerned about my slider.
Shut up.
You're not my legal advisor.
You're saying that because Joe said that the main character scary Perry and
Wendy's city eat was crazy.
Now it's got that police could not have it.
Yeah.
That guy could not have existed without the comedy store.
The comedy store is like the magnet for the craziest fucking people from all
over the world would be drawn to that place.
You're never fucking people that we met at that place.
How about that?
That fucking hooker,
the crazy hooker that was on camera just telling me about,
she puts an ad in craigslist,
just shows up at God's houses and fucks him.
And that's the old way to do it.
Nowadays you just become a porn star.
Is that what they're doing?
Porn Star hookers.
It seems like everyone's a porn star.
Well,
it kind of makes sense.
It'd be like good advertising.
If you really wanted to be a hooker,
you would do porn and say,
you know,
you could be you.
It could be fucking this right now.
And you know,
and then they put an ad out,
you know that it's crazy.
It's that there's this one porn star that's pretty
well no,
and I'm not going to say who it is and I searched her and found her on like a
one of those hooker,
a review websites.
Have you seen these where they review hookers?
It's like,
it's like,
it's like Amazon where like that girl's pussy smiled but she did put out,
you know,
and it was good and you know,
anyways,
I found her on there and you could like,
it gives her rates and reviews and it also gives her mobile cell phone number so
you can just call her up.
I was like,
this is ridiculous.
This website,
what's the name of uh,
fuck.
I can't remember.
That's a good thing for people to know.
That is insane.
I can't remember.
I'm sure people are going to start twitching.
Reviews are always hilarious when you go Yelp and someone's
taken the time to write a serious lead paragraph review about a cafe,
thoughtful,
thoughtful review like their Siskel and Ebert and they're reviewing like the,
the Sherman oaks.
Starbucks.
Well,
I think some folks have like they have aspirations like,
hey,
I'll start out reviewing shit on Yelp and then I'll start a blog because people
enjoy my Yelp reviews.
And next thing you know,
a Gq will hire me to be their resident critic because of my snarky reviews.
Sad,
sad.
Pat,
I'm so snarky.
I really know how to cut you down.
Yeah.
You down to size.
The snarky reviews suck.
But what's even more unnerving is when someone gives like a passionate,
a positive review for a Shoney's.
All right.
You know what I mean?
Or if someone likes Shoney's,
Denny's,
you know what I mean?
Or for like,
uh,
if you go on Yelp,
you can look at reviews for like,
um,
uh,
office depot or staples.
I hope I'm a Yelp elite.
Are you a Yelp elite?
Yeah.
How many times they actually,
you did two things today.
You made fun of him.
This,
the,
the second one.
The salvia videos and the yellow.
Yeah.
He's a Salvia video and he's an ELP cards.
Sorry,
I don't mean to,
I'm not talking about you.
His reviews are great.
I see your reviews are hilarious.
Sometimes you get,
you know,
something that you hate and you want to make sure that if people are driving
around going,
let's go to a restaurant,
Bam,
oh,
this is something to know.
For the most part,
this is four stars.
You know,
I,
your reviews are different.
Like I like,
I like access of information.
You have to come off the ledge.
Come on.
Yeah.
But would you take your sweetie to a restaurant if you like,
looked at the reviews and it says,
you know,
chef farts and on every plate before giving it to you?
Maybe if it was one review that said that,
yes,
that would be,
I would still be down.
There was a restaurant where a chef farted on the plates I might get best is
when you go to people's,
uh,
if you follow that stuff,
if you go to their review site where you know,
you look at all the reviews and they're all negative to just a rotten,
can't write angry at everything they see everywhere they go.
I like it,
especially for dentists and doctors.
So you went to this doctor has 9,000 reviews.
All positive and except one negative.
I'm going to go to that doctor,
you know.
Well there's people that will complain about Dunkin.
When you take these,
you know,
harsh hits.
To me it really hurts because you're not really thinking it out.
I didn't think he's helping man.
How many reviews are you,
do you have on your Yelp?
I don't know.
A lot.
I love Yelp.
I just girls,
the girls ever yelled at you and they send you Yelp messages like I really loved
how you reviewed that Taco Bell.
Oh I have a lot dude.
I love your writing.
Yup.
Actually has parties for all the Yelp elites.
And then when you go there and this bomb on you it's like Oh my God,
it's like 40 people like 39 of them are Asian girls and then you know,
so it's like what,
where did they have the part until we had it as last year when you walked in the
room,
we had a Christmas party at the viper room last year.
That would suck that 40 Yelp reviewers in your establishment.
Cause one of them,
it's going to leave Shitty Ryan walks.
No totally purple leisure shoes and you get served better because he'd like make
me print out a Yelp badge and put it in her wallet and then you could like flip
it when you go to the hostess stand and they automatically serve you better and
try harder and cook her food.
But just kidding.
I don't today.
Okay.
You went too far with that one son.
You should have bailed on that one.
Earlier you knew it was a stinker.
How many,
how many Asian checks have you met from these things?
Not many accident dining.
I've only gone once.
A few of you dated any of these agents now,
why not just fucked him on,
hey,
this is a family show.
You're going to fuck up here.
You look at it and you go,
Hey,
I'm a single man now I'm out there.
Yelping
nothing makes me feel better after I get out of a bad relationship then right.
Riding a Yelp review.
We'd stores.
Lately I've been yelping.
Oh yeah,
that's,
I mean,
it's cool because like you go,
you read these reviews and go,
hey,
these people,
you don't have a cash machine.
They'd do credit cards.
I do review Yelp.
I mean,
I read the reviews,
but I do not review things and that's really selfish for me.
I'm a fucking one way street.
Yeah.
You're like,
uh Oh.
Downloading torrents,
sharing.
I enjoy your reviews on Yelp,
but outside of red band,
it's just,
it's just to me like when you read some of the impassioned and passion Yelper
view where someone's really that pissed off that they're like writing an angry
Yelp review.
It's always,
some of them are so dumb.
What bothers me when they start complaining about the prices,
you know,
and it's so overpriced and this and that and that this,
and I don't care how good the food is.
$39 for a steak.
It's ridiculous.
Well,
no,
it's not.
If the guy goes to the butcher,
mark himself and make sure he's only getting grass fed beef from very specific
organic cows and he brings to his restaurant.
This is the whole point of what he's serving you is like the berry best shit
from all over the world and you're complaining that it costs a few dollars more.
Like,
do you not understand what he's doing here?
How about the old,
the reason I gave this three stars instead of four stars is because when we came
into the restaurant it's just like,
yeah,
the,
the hostess was eating her own meal and had to finish your mouthful before she
could speak to us.
I got in trouble for one review because I was so pissed off that it went home
and did one of these like really bad reviews that you guys are talking about,
gave it one star,
posted the photo as being a kid with like hair missing,
you know,
like from his head for some reason.
You're like a patch of hair and I got in trouble for it.
Why did you get in trouble?
Uh,
just because of what I wrote.
Who'd you get in trouble from?
Well,
what did you write?
Uh,
what do you want me to read a little bit though?
I wrote,
well it was a $7 haircut and the guy fucked up your hair and then you put a
picture that wasn't really you fucked up hair and said it was you.
Yeah.
So you did a douchey thing?
No,
no,
no.
She just acted like she'd never like cut hair in her life.
Like I was telling her things and she would like cut,
start cutting the,
the,
it was,
she was hit by your beauty,
but uh,
anyways,
we should have busted a move when were sitting over.
Maybe that was what it was,
man.
Maybe you just put the spell on that bitch she to do with your pheromone
click.
I really thought that she got her like barbershop license from like,
she thought the warranty card for the clippers was like her,
you know,
and that's all she needed or something.
It was that bad.
Like she never cut heroin and for frowns upon Newseum right there.
Brian frowns frowns upon O'Brien.
Chief is not happy.
The dance of destruction.
Not Happy.
Isn't s Shiva supposed to be the god of cannabis?
Yes.
Yeah.
There's a city in India.
Uh,
I called Vara Nosse.
Um,
where they cremate,
it's is the city on the Ganges River where they cremate all the bodies.
Um,
and I went there and a marijuana is legal there because apparently at the end of
the age of Kali Yoga as Shiva is beginning to destroy the universe,
which is now this is called you explain that before you get into anything,
because a lot of people don't know what the fuck we're talking about,
but the,
is the Hindus believe that there are these ages?
Yeah.
It's like the,
you know,
it's like the cycles of time,
and I don't know the names of all the ages,
but the one we're in right now,
it's basically based on the idea that it's almost based on like devos premise,
which is that we're d evolving and not evolving.
So like in its devos premise,
yeah.
Divo d evolution.
That's what the students are like.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
I did not know that until right now.
Yeah.
So just thought they had cool music.
No,
man,
they're the de evolution people.
Yeah,
it's cool.
But,
um,
gates of steel man.
So Kali Yoga is what we're in basically.
The idea is this,
when you have fresh fruit over time it kind of rots when you have a flower.
It wilts humanities the same way.
There's a cycle.
There's a golden age when that started.
Humans or super intelligent,
super tuned in with the universe and we're just wilting and rotting.
I as we,
as we reproduce at massive rates,
we're diluting the gene lines and there were,
we're now it apparently in the middle of the age of colleague or at the very
beginning of the middle of the age of Kali Yoga and the symptoms at the age of
Kali Yoga are forgetfulness.
Um,
okay.
He like,
uh,
people are lazy.
Um,
in so technology,
what we consider to be a sign of things advancing is actually a sign of things
collapsing.
The fact that we need technology and that our focus has turned towards all the
different things that people think are important now only shows that we've
gotten really,
really stupid.
When in the beginning of time when there wasn't that many people,
um,
language wasn't necessary.
It's kind of like there's an anarchist,
what the fuck is that guy's name?
I shouldn't have said his name.
He's really,
he's really intense.
And he shares a similar viewpoint.
Uh,
someone out there has got to know this guy is an anti technologist.
and he believes that,
um,
language and symbols and paintings and drawings and all of these things are
aberrations and that before that,
that the very act of translating the universe into a symbol is a lie because you
can't translate the universe into assemble.
And so the,
when people started doing cave drawings to depict the universe,
this was the beginning of the collapse of society.
Because what you're interpreting reality in a way that isn't really reality,
you know the thing when you're in a conversation with somebody and you know,
you both agree,
you can't find the language to express it.
Right?
And so you just stay in a fight,
right?
Even though you know,
underneath it all,
it's like it's something that's like,
you both are on the same page somehow.
Right?
So anyway,
the whole point is as the golden age,
people didn't have language.
They didn't,
they didn't or didn't have a written form.
They didn't need it.
And then as things began to collapse,
the written form evolved and all the variants of it.
And now we're in the age of Carla.
You go where everyone's completely,
you know,
forgotten everything.
So how many times did they,
the Hindus think that these cycles have repeated themselves over and over and
over.
That question.
Cause the way they,
the way they explain it is they say to know how many times this cycle is
happening again and again,
which is the idea is it's the creator breathes the universe out and then sucks
it back in.
It's the,
it's the pattern of breath.
So the number of times that this has happened,
imagine the Himalayas,
right?
And imagine that once some people say a year,
some people say every hundred years I dove flies over that very top peak of the
Himalayas with a scarf,
a silk scarf,
and the silk scarf touches the very top peak.
Imagine the number of times,
imagine that,
that the Himalayas had been ground down into a valley.
That's how many times the universe has been born and destroyed.
That number of times,
the amount of times it would take a s a dove carrying a scarf to erode it.
Of course,
this is not precise math ideas.
The idea is it's infinite.
It's literally possible to put a number on it.
It's impossible.
So this is,
these,
these ages have been anticipated over and over and over again.
Yeah.
And so do they believe,
how long do they believe that human beings have been here?
I don't know.
They do have a number for it.
So they don't believe that human beings are,
are,
you know,
a few hundred thousand years old or a million years old.
They think we're way,
way older than that.
And they think that they're,
and then this is the millionth version of a human universe is teeming with life.
Wow.
Now,
what about the Vedas?
Did you,
did you read about that?
Does,
sure.
It does.
Explain what that is.
So the,
the,
um,
the Vedas are the,
uh,
the,
collected.
There's different,
the collected works of Hinduism,
which are,
uh,
which is filled with like references to flying saucers and spaces.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
yeah,
exactly.
It's,
it's,
they use the term gods are Demigodz and they believe that when
there is,
if there was flying things to the sky,
what did they call those things?
I don't know about that.
I want to say [inaudible].
No,
I don't know.
Well,
they had no,
there's like,
I can't remember the name.
There are like flying chariots and stuff like that.
Yeah.
But I mean that's an,
that's an every,
that's an almost every religion.
There's like reports of flying weird flying things like,
uh,
at the book of Ezekiel,
the Prophet is obviously a Ufo.
If it's anything,
it's someone talking about it uses a wheel within a wheel.
Yeah.
But yeah,
we're in the age of Kali Yoga and this is the age of disintegration and
everyone's dumb and everybody thinks the most important thing is like fucking
and reproducing.
And what happens next?
I suppose what happens next is the apocalypse where,
where you meet your,
what is supposedly in it accordingly
to the,
uh,
the Hindus.
What is the next state like?
We go through this,
this,
uh,
you know,
current.
So there's the depiction.
If you look up Colley who is,
uh,
Chivas consort,
then you'll see this image of this like crazy,
wild haired woman.
Crazy bitch.
We're in the year of the crazy bitch.
Yeah.
And behind,
I'm not,
I would never call a colleague that,
but by just out of pure superstition.
But behind Kali is,
this is humanity,
right?
So you see fire and all of humanity and there's an apocalypse happening and
Carly's wearing around her neck,
a garland of heads.
And those,
the,
those heads represent the gods.
So she's literally decapitated all of the gods and carries their heads around
this and wearing their heads.
And she's holding weapons in our hands.
But on one hand she's holding a flower and that flower represents the next
phase,
so it's like the idea is like kind of what's happening right now,
which is holy shit,
he's cool.
We've gotten so smart that now we know of course there's not a god with a beard
and there's not a blue skinned God with forearms and there's not.
I mean there there could be super intelligent life,
but by now we know that the symbol systems that ancient people are using to
describe divinity or just that symbol systems.
We've deconstructed it now to the point where we're starting to understand that
these things,
the way they were described,
that's kind of like a fairy tale.
Do you subscribe to the idea that most of these people that have described all
these incredible experiences really stumbled upon psychedelics?
Do you think that a lot of these people were tripping and that's where all these
things came from?
Where do you think it's like Ufo is like what do you,
what do you think is the,
the basis for all these different religions,
especially like the Hindus and stuff,
when you get to stuff that gets really like really like a science fiction,
he almost,
I,
I get into the multiple histories of the universe theory and the idea that
we're,
where we're existing right now,
there's an infinite number of parallel universes that are all happening around
us.
And I think that if this would create some kind of like if you,
there's like an actual,
like this sounds crazy,
but I think if you were smart enough you could map it out with coordinates,
like all the different alternate realities and in these possible dose infinite
though,
how could
you map them?
I think you could to some certain degree.
I think that there's certain levels of experience that have been mapped out and
have been encoded in the form of religion and those levels of experience.
Our encounters with divinity and weather.
And so when,
and I think Mckenna said this,
you know,
when you get into the whole Ufo thing and the alien thing and the higher
intelligence thing,
the,
the extra terrestrial and the interdimensional being kind of become the same
thing.
So to me it's very easy to believe that there's life on other planets.
And I think that's a very high,
they're the,
the,
that's,
it's impossible to not believe that in fact,
based on what people say about the expansiveness of the universe.
But I also think that outside of that existing around us at all times are other
levels of experience.
And we know this because we know about the spectrum of light and there's,
you hear it over and over again,
radio waves that if you could tune in and you could listen to rush Limbaugh
right now.
But I think just in that way there's also,
right,
or that you don't see in touch,
but they're there.
There's higher levels of experience.
Other than that.
Now you have talked about your dime methyl tryptamine experience and other
people have reported this experience.
And when they talk about it,
there's two possibilities.
Well,
there's two basic possibilities.
One,
the human mind is so fucking powerful that somehow under the influence of this
drug,
it can actually construct an alternate dimension with super mathematical
geometries that are almost impossible to describe and so potent that it
apparently makes people feel like they're going to die from astonishment is
Terence Mckenna says,
and I believe you said the same thing.
Yeah,
that's another possibility.
They literally tell you to relax,
right?
We tell you to relax and try to take it all in.
Do you think that that's your subconscious trying to tell you that you can find
an experience here that you can take something from this and you should learn
how to like let it happen?
Or do you think that something's actually communicating with you?
That's where it gets like,
really who the fuck knows?
We'll see.
That's the funny thing about it is it's like this whole apple have said,
I'm sorry to interrupt you here.
People have said about that experience that the,
they could never have thought that up on their own.
So they know that there's something that was communicating with them.
But I say that's bullshit.
You could know if you were under the influence of a drug,
like maybe your brain become super powered and your creativity becomes so
powerful that you manifest something that you actually believe is a real thing
and it's only because something in your brain is getting jabbed with some new
chemical.
I mean the,
we ha,
I mean nobody wants that possibility to be real.
Everybody wants,
you know,
the idea that my romantic vision is that you're tuning into another dementia and
that you're communicating with aliens,
but it's also just as possible that your imagination is fucking insanely
powerful because you know you're supposed to be able to create all sorts of
things that allow people to change the world.
It's the iceberg theory of the human mind that we,
the very tip,
we only use 10% of our,
that's all bullshit though.
That's all been proven to be just ignorant.
You can't say the only,
we only use a certain percentage of our brain,
but you know,
there are percentages of our brain that get used for different things.
You,
you can certainly make the brain work better.
And do different things.
If you add,
you know,
electrical charges to it,
if you add chemicals to it,
you know,
you can get it to do weird things.
Well,
I'm more of a
fiesta than you are and,
and I,
I do think that there are,
I think there are higher levels of intelligence that have their own
consciousness.
I'm open to that idea.
I'm open to it,
but I also see no evidence of it.
So I'm open to it.
I'm,
I'm 100% open to it,
but I'm not going to commit to it.
I would never say that.
That is what I think is real.
My problem is I think when you start thinking like that,
when there's no evidence that gets silly,
it gets slippery and you start looking for shit.
It's not that.
Yes,
I agree.
You could be very sloppy with this kind of stuff,
but you're not sloppy.
I know you,
you,
you do come from a very real,
yeah.
It's the logic man.
It's like,
so here's the logic.
The logic is,
okay,
do the first question is,
do you believe that we are the only intelligent beings in an infinite universe?
And so there's a group of people who believe that,
and okay,
they're foolish right off the bat.
You,
you'd have to be foolish to believe that.
You'd have to be foolish to know.
Why would you say that?
You could ever have the knowledge,
it's impossible at this current stage of the game.
It is an open answer.
You cannot answer it.
You should never say,
do you believe there is intelligent life in university?
I have no information.
I have nothing,
but it's all just speculation.
Yeah.
For me logically,
just because the universe is apparently infinite and space,
whatever that means,
it's a very big place.
And just because we're,
you know,
every day they come back with like,
we just found another,
uh,
a planet that's uh,
a planet around a sun and they have the idea,
the goldilocks region,
which they call the perfect place next to the sun where you need to be for life
to exist.
And based on just the few that they found,
that implication is that there's obviously,
and you know this backwards and forwards,
there's millions of planets surrounding signs and based on that,
there is an extremely high probability that there's other life out there,
right?
Yeah.
But it could be other life that's so alien to us that we can't even recognize
it.
We don't have the senses to depict it.
It doesn't have to be carbon based.
They could have their good be beings made of light,
intelligent life made of air,
you know,
made of a gas.
We don't,
we don't put gigantic beings that are the size of our galaxy.
I mean we might be experiencing that right now.
I mean what I was used,
what are called the Fort Theory that if you didn't have a nose and someone
farther do,
you have no idea you're sitting there and someone's stench.
How do we not know that they are not an infinite number of senses that we don't
possess to detect an infinite amount of things that are around us all the time.
We just don't have any,
any census for,
we don't have the ability to tune into it.
That's possible.
It just,
the only thing that limits that is our own imagination.
If space can be infinite,
so can possibilities.
If the,
if the universe literally isn't an infinite place or as close to infinite as is
possible,
then so are the possibilities through,
so the possibilities of all sorts of different things,
you know about the a and the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy,
the improbability drive?
No.
What does that have you read?
The hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy?
It's a very funny good.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
I mean,
I,
to be honest,
I haven't read it since,
uh,
I was in high school,
so that's probably a little cheesy now if I read it.
But I still think about it from time to time.
And the device that drives the spaceships or one of their spaceships is called
an improbability drive.
And it basically came into existence on its own because it was so improbable
that it would come into existence.
So it sort of manifested itself,
which is funny because,
um,
and the idea of in the idea of time machines,
one of the ways that they think it might happen is it might just sort of come
into existence on its own if you just create the right circumstance for it
anyway.
The,
well,
it makes sense.
All you have to do is you don't have to really have to Korea at a time machine.
You just have to create a portal for a time machine to use.
Well,
you know,
the MIT,
the time machine will show up from the future,
you know,
the MIT experiment that they did know.
So MIT had this idea,
which is like,
okay,
you know,
if there's time travel,
why haven't we seen time travelers yet?
And so what they did is they,
the,
the theory was,
well,
we'll,
we'll create a press conference with shitloads of scientists,
almost like a party where a time traveler can come to this moment and
communicate whatever he needs to communicate to,
um,
to the world.
And so they threw this big thing where they had cameras and scientists and all
this shit.
Because the idea being that at whatever point in the future that time travels
invented,
they would no knows that back to this year was this to do this.
I think it was like the 80s the Haiti,
nobody showed up shit back then.
Nobody showed up.
No scientists showed up either now time traveler,
no time travel.
But yeah,
the scientists showed up.
Well what they believe is the none.
That's just,
you know,
they is,
might as well be talking about fucking the x man.
You know the fuck they are using that word.
But what scientists believe is that when the first time machine is invented,
that will be the moment that all other time travelers from now until eternity
get to come back to that point in any point in between,
they'll be able to flow freely through time.
Once the door has been open and until that door is open,
there will be no time.
Travelers,
when we first started hanging out,
you gave me a marijuana lollipop.
This is like right at the beginning of our friendship and I didn't know anything
about eating fat or how strong it was or whatever.
And I still remember this eating it and then you had just started led,
let me open up for you on the road and I think it was after a show or driving
back and I'd eat one of these things and I'd never heard you say that idea of a
four.
And I remember you saying that.
And right at that moment that pot started kicking in and I was like,
oh Jesus Christ.
I think it was so intense,
man.
I thought I saw alien heads floating in.
The Sky was just so freaked out cause ideas so crazy.
But what's really crazy is look just like the atomic bomb,
the time machine
is not just possible.
It's inevitable.
Yeah.
If they're going to keep searching,
if technology keeps increasing at the exponential rate that it always has been
increasing yet with its complexity with innovation,
they're going to get more and more information about matter and the universe and
time and they're going to get more and more power,
more and more ability to process things.
I mean they just figured out a new,
some sort of a,
a new chip that operates on light,
some quantum leap in,
in,
in chip technology.
And that computers are going to be like infinitely more powerful soon than they
are now.
Right?
Think time machines,
the first time machine is actually going to be invented in your head.
Meaning they're going to program your head to go back then into 1940s and you
know,
before they actually will go back.
And David,
but I think if you can think of it,
it's possible,
right?
That's a cool,
you know,
it's going to open up your mind.
It's going to open up your telescope for time.
Right.
You can peer back and watch it.
Maybe you're,
you feel like you're in it.
You're feel like you're back in 1940 you know,
but your brain's just making you think you're in 19 yeah,
I,
I've been talking about Tom Machines a lot on stage lately,
man.
I've been doing a lot of time machine material.
You know,
I just think the idea,
the concept is so fascinating and the grandfather paradox is so fancy.
Fascinating that it's such a stupid reason for people to believe that a time
machine can never exist.
Right.
It is a true story that I tell on stage that actually really did happen where a
guy came up to me and said that your your time machine joke is funny,
but time machines are possible.
The guy like wanting to argue the time machines can never be impossible because
of the grandfathers.
Oh Great.
You know the grandfather paradox,
the paradox is if a time machine was real,
you could go back in time and kill your grandfather before your father was ever
born.
Thus he can never been born to make a time machine.
Right.
Just like the most ridiculous logic ever.
Like just because first of all,
just because you could go back in time and kill your grandfather and you would
cease to exist.
Just because you could do that doesn't mean you wouldn't do that.
It means you could and maybe people would and yeah,
they would cease to exist and yeah,
it would break time.
I mean,
yeah,
it's possible that people could really go back in time.
They could break time.
You know about John t door?
No,
that's nonsense.
Well,
no,
he,
it is nonsense of course.
But his,
the way that he dealt with that paradox,
which I think is really smart,
is that when you're traveling back in time and not really traveling back in
time,
you're traveling into an alternate,
like multiple universe,
her similar to ours and the further back you go,
which is a really smart thing that he added to the hoax because it's like,
it made it so that his predictions could be off a lot because we're not in this
dimension because they're not in this dimension.
But like the further back you go,
the more the timelines kind of starts splitting apart and diverging.
So events aren't,
don't line up exactly the same way.
So it's a great,
it's the idea of infinite
universes,
saddens people.
You know what,
it just,
when something looks that big,
it makes people depressed.
Now when you tell people like maybe there are infinite lives that we are all
living,
you know,
all consecutively,
all right next to each other and they're all completely different.
The idea that I was like,
oh,
it's like I am just barely getting the pack.
The fact that um,
you know,
living here in America on earth in 2010,
I'm barely,
barely wrapping my head around that.
The idea that there's billions and billions and then that we're going to Redo
this every 15 billion years because it's going to be a new,
big bang and people are going to eventually evolve out of Amoebas and fish and
fucking lizards and rabbits and monkeys and humans.
Really.
It just keeps going over and over and over and over and over and over again.
Can I tell you my new theory of reincarnation?
Yes.
And it's really intense because I thought of this and it freaked me out.
It's pretty horrible.
So it's like that common idea of reincarnation,
if you subscribed to the theory is that you die and you're born again.
You go through your childhood,
did you grow up and then you die.
Maybe you get born as a cat,
maybe a butterfly,
right?
Maybe an Amoeba.
This is what I was thinking.
Cause I had a dream months and in this dream I was a kid,
a little girl,
and my mom was rubbing my head and I knew I was dying,
but I didn't know what that meant except I knew it was bad and I could kind of
feel myself fading out.
There was this like white sort of thing happening and then I woke up out of the
dream like,
fuck,
what is shitty dream?
So I was thinking like,
Oh fuck,
what if that's what reincarnation is?
What if when you die,
you know when you're driving home one night you've had too many pot while he
pops,
you're listening to coast to coast.
Someone says something shocking that makes you look away from the road.
You swerve off,
you slam into a tree,
you wake up,
you're here back in your house like,
Oh fuck,
what is shitty dream?
But you've really died.
You just reincarnated again into an ultimate reality in an alternate reality.
So you literally can't die.
There's no break.
This just goes on forever and ever and ever and ever.
No break,
no stopping,
no new age.
Going into the light and seeing your parents and your family and taking a,
going to some new age cosmic spa where you get to shake off all your shitty
Karma.
It never stops.
It just keeps happening again.
Again,
maybe like right now there's an earthquake and the ceiling collapses and all of
a sudden you're just some daydreaming cabby and Boston like,
wow,
that was fucking weird.
I was just imagining I was a comedian in la,
but you know what I mean?
Well,
that's bizarre.
You're going to change lives.
Snap into another role.
Life.
You become the guy rides this body out.
Yeah.
You snap into an alternate life with all your memories.
Right.
Embedded everything already embedded in there because it's an infinite,
it's an infinite.
This,
the the,
it goes on forever.
What if your consciousness is living a bunch of different lives simultaneously
and you just can't,
you can't see them.
It's like a,
an office filled with cubicles and no one's poking their head over the top of
the cubicle.
Yeah,
right.
We're all rolling at the same time.
Or like the way I thought about it is like if you're,
if there was like some,
this,
it sounds really crazy,
but imagine that each of your fingers,
it sounds insane,
but imagine like each of your fingers had their own personality and their own
like consciousness or something.
It's like,
and you could stick them through some kind of hole where they
would forget they were attached to your hand and they would just think that they
were their own individual selves.
You know what I mean?
Like maybe that's what we are.
We're just like little fingers protruding into this dimension from some infinite
thing,
but the product of protruding into this dimension as we get instantaneous
amnesia and part of like dealing with a shock of coming into this dimension is
we forget our true identity and replace it with our ego structures.
Wow.
Well,
one of the things that,
uh,
okay,
yes.
On one of the things that,
uh,
you did,
quite a bunch when you were my roommate Duncan live with me a few years back for
a few months,
happy,
happy.
It wasn't a few months.
It was like three weeks,
two or three weeks.
It was that you are so,
it was so awesome.
Anyway,
Dunkin,
one of my best friends,
great guy and um,
came over and was getting the tank all the time.
So for me it was fascinating because I,
I've offered the tank to so many of my friends.
I've offered to so many people,
but there's something about it that weirds people the fuck out.
You know,
very few of them.
Tate,
when Tate lived here,
he barely got in that thing and I was like,
yeah,
will you not in that thing every day we have the opportunity to literally,
that is a gateway to the center of the universe.
That's a fucking spaceship right there.
That's a spaceship to innerspace.
Yeah,
you're climbing that thing.
You're going to get rocket into,
into interspace.
It's right there.
It's in the basement.
You're going to use that shit.
But for whatever reason,
most most dudes are scared of it.
You jumped in that thing,
man.
You were in that thing a lot.
Well because at for a very long time I've wanted to go on those.
One of those things cause I was,
you know,
I knew about John Lilly and also of course the altered states.
The movie where the Guy Turns into a monkey.
Yeah.
Always wanting to want to go.
I want to go on that one now.
Yeah.
That fucking thing.
If you haven't seen his tank,
it's evolved.
When I was,
when I was here,
you subpoenas old tank,
didn't you?
When you used to go in it,
you said you did.
I didn't pee in a urinal ass so I never,
I've net branch,
but the old tank was like,
it was cool looking.
But this fucking thing looks like a holodeck down there at some steel giant
weird things like a frigerator.
Yeah,
it's the,
that's the,
that's the mothership man.
That thing puts you into,
right.
Shoot you in an interspace.
I mean really,
it's really what it is.
I mean split.
What is space,
you know,
spaces.
You're supposed to be flying out into the infinite.
Yeah.
Well,
there's no space like the fucking space in your head because that truly is
infinite,
right?
You'd have to worry about running into asteroids or there's nothing out there.
I mean,
it's just free open energy and know your body is not connected.
It's just the line.
Well,
when I was staying with you,
it was because I had been living with a girl and the whole thing collapsed.
I don't want to talk about that.
But it was really cool to go into the well.
So when I,
when I moved into Virgo with Joe,
he was very kind and he's like,
you have unlimited access to my weed,
my flotation tank,
which was a super,
I mean,
if you've ever been out just getting out of a shitty relationship,
that is like an incredible gift to give someone.
But the combination of the weed and the flotation tank and just,
uh,
just everything collapsing around you when you go into,
when I went into the tank the first time,
you know,
there's like a,
where nothing's
really happening.
You got to learn to relax.
But all of a sudden,
the big experience I had was all these like memories of their relationship
started appearing in front of me.
Like,
and this sounds so seminar.
Like when you,
you know,
when you do a,
um,
multi chat on apple,
you know what I mean?
I swear to God,
it was like,
oh,
that's when we were at the beach and oh,
that's when we first met.
And then just there and it's all playing out in this like compete with such
great detail that uh,
I,
my normal memories never works like that,
but it was,
you could just see these things happening that you never noticed before and you
would just come out of the tank after having these vivid memories completely
depressed.
Like,
thanks tank.
Thanks for walking me through my miserable relationship.
But you know,
if I have more time machine,
I'm sure it's better.
Well,
you know,
what it is,
is those are the things that are bothering you.
Those are the memories that you're suppressing those.
That's the pain.
The fact that you were deeply in love when you were in this beautiful place and
now you're,
you're without it.
Yeah.
Now it's been taken away from you like a limb limb that you miss like a part of
your,
one of your organs or something,
a part of your soul and the tank wants you to be aware of that and the tank once
all the things that fuck with you.
Like I don't,
I can't have any secrets in my head and go in the tank.
There's no secrets there.
Anything.
You don't want to talk about tax like,
Hey,
what's that right there?
Yeah,
let's go.
Let's get this out in the front.
Yeah,
let's pull this out in the front and get a spotlight on it.
You know,
it's like anything that's fucking with your head.
It's the key to not,
I don't want to say enlightenment,
but the key to peace,
the key to peace with the human mind is dealing with all your issues.
Anything that's bothering you,
anything that's you're not doing right,
anything.
The tank exposes,
all that Shit.
Very psychedelic in that respect.
Whereas it's very introspective,
like deep and sort of somewhat kind of abrasive and disturbing,
you know?
Yeah.
Forces,
it forces you to look at yourself.
Well,
it always is.
I mean that's the thing I'd always,
anything you're,
you're trying to ignore as always.
It's always disturbing.
It's like puking,
right?
But it's psychedelic experience.
Drags that stuff out always.
And that's why people are always like,
no,
I would
never,
I don't like smoking pot because it makes me nervous.
It makes me anxious.
And it's like,
well,
yeah,
yeah.
Really.
It's not making you anxious.
It's like the fact that you're deeply in debt and,
or you're a whatever the millions of things you're trying to pretend aren't
happening in your,
what are your,
an alcoholic,
whatever,
all the things you're trying to deny that right under the surface.
And when you
that comes,
comes up and you have to deal with it.
You can't have any soccer,
you can't hide your secrets from weed.
Weed's too smart
and the end ladies Joe,
right?
I think that's a,
the end of the podcast.
It is now six 48 so it was probably like two and a half hours.
Right.
Awesome.
Long Ass fucking time.
Thank you very much to the fleshlight our sponsor,
as always,
we hung out with those guys in Austin.
You gotta check out Dunkin side podcasts by the way.
It's fucking hilarious.
Oh yeah.
What is your plug?
Your podcast,
the lavender hour and is it on iTunes?
Yeah,
it's on iTunes.
The lavender hour.
It changed me and Natasha was here and um,
you know,
you could see Dunkin Dunkin.
Do you have a calendar up on your website or on your Twitter is no calendar App.
I go up at the comedy store pretty regularly so people listen because a lot of
people don't know.
By the way,
the iTunes folks,
this is all these episodes that you're listening to on iTunes are also available
on Ustream.
If you wanted a watch,
you can watch something.
I don't know if you're just bored,
you want to watch something you can do a lot of,
are you,
I know.
Listen to this stuff in your car and the train on the way to work or something
like that,
but if you ever want to watch it,
they're all available on Ustream and if you are watching on Ustream,
you could see Dunkin's Twitter address,
which is Dunkin,
d,
u n c a n Trussell,
t r u s s e l,
l and a.
You can find them on Twitter and you're always doing gigs around town,
right around La.
Most of the time you go on the road with Natasha sometimes.
Yeah.
How did you go to,
you went to a Denver,
right?
No,
we're going to Denver.
When you going to guide me,
I don't remember the day.
It will be on my output.
A dates thing on my website should have that.
I'm stupid and not do that.
Yeah,
get on the date son fucking idea and utilize that Internet.
But anyway,
dude,
always,
always cool talking a little.
By the way,
go search Duncan Trussell kidnapped one of the funniest videos he's ever done.
Okay.
Duncan Trussell kidnaps and a,
the other one was drunk and history,
a drug and history number.
Just look up drunk history,
Tesla and I'll pop the drunk history Tesla.
Anyway,
thank you Duncan.
Always cozy and you my friend have you on for the longest time.
Thank you everybody.
And um,
we will be the next one will be this Thursday.
We're doing Doug Stanhope.
Stan hope's going to be here on Thursday.
That'd be fun.
And we're going to go to Stan help show Wednesday night if you're in town,
but he is at the Irvine Improv and as of yesterday,
at least a few tickets are still available.
So snatch those bitches up cause a Stan hope is,
he's a fucking,
he's the real deal.
He's the real shit.
You know,
there's,
you know,
there's a few guys that I go out of my way to see when they come in town.
Louis C K is one of them.
And Stan hope is another one.
You know,
I think he's one of the very best out there,
don't you think?
Oh yeah,
he's awesome.
And he's a great fucking guy.
And we did a Shitty TV show together.
Anyway,
thank you everybody.
And we'll see you on Thursday.
Love you bitches.
Bye.